I had to go off again today about how like Bosch is actually
do we just trust Bosch on everything from now on? Bosch is like
more powerful than every tarot card like you don't have to watch.
>> The other day came to my chat and said Joe just he said
this exactly super wait. Are you going to read the exact screenshot
you sent me that I didn't respond to when you sent it to me on
my stream? Is that what you want to do right now? That's what
you want to do? >> Let me read this out. Let me read this
out. Let me read this out real quick. So he says, >> Anyway,
that's it for the stream now.
Speaking of totally unhinged, I did I did have this clip from
somebody else in my docket here. Watch it. >> Elon Musk,
apparently at some Tommy Robinson like rally thing. >> Whether
you choose bounce or not, bounce is coming to you. >> Dude,
dude, dude, dude, dude. You You have to watch some of this rally.
You have to watch some of this. It's so funny. This rally is
so funny. >> You found some gems in bonger politics
Yeah, it's actually in the chat. >> Oh, wait. Did you see
that Destiny clip that O just posted like an hour ago? >> Well,
the one that you've pinned. >> Yeah, that one. >> Yeah,
sorry. Cuz you pinned it. Yeah, >> dude. No, I just think
it's hilarious that like he really wants off that tour. Like,
absolutely. Like, that's his number one priority right now. Let
me not go out. I just want to go outside. Also, you're quite
quiet. >> Uh I don't I don't I can't read. >> That's
way better. >> This is okay. >> Whatever you just
did. Yeah. Infinitely better. I'll restart this real quick. >> Yeah.
Yeah, I saw the Destiny stuff. This guy's going crazy.
>> Like I think uh it's just funny to me that like >> the
issue is the issue with my p that panel uh is Destiny's going
crazy and he's taking like one or two steps too far in the where
where we're at right now, if you know what I mean. >> He's
not that far off, but you know, it it's like one or two steps,
but there's no one there to like actually
uh challenge that. It's like just scum like Tarly Bots who is
just like total dirt filth subhuman. >> Dude, it was so
like she literally is just trying to suck him off like live on
the panel. It's so weird. I don't even
>> And literally is she literally thinks that he's going
to be like, >> "Yeah, yeah, the the left are really bad."
Yeah, the left are You're also right, Ty. Yeah, is really bad.
Because that is the logical conclusion of the this guy says on
stream every day. And I find it so funny whenever this loser
is confronted with a complete was bought into everything he says
and he see he has to argue with like the natural conclusion of
some [__] he said. It's like this is that's exactly
what is happening with Tardy Bots. I think it happens to someone
else on the panel at some point as well where it's just like
yeah if you sit there crying about how crazy Assan is all day
when he's not even that crazy and 90% of the times you're crying
about him like it's actually not even that bad usually >> dude.
Okay. Uh
>> okay. Sorry. Yeah. This is how people this this is how
people are going to see the world. This is how some Israeli
is going to see the Democratic party now. They're infiltrated
by anti-semitic communists who are going to kill me that that
Yeah. No. >> Yeah. Yeah.
And the best part about this is is now with the Charlie Kirk
thing, um, they had this argument and I didn't quite connect
it in the same way back when it was the Trump thing, but Desi
had this thing where he's like, yeah, um, if I'm talking to people
and it's conservatives, I will never disavow the violence to
conservatives. And I'm like, wait, how did anybody who's a DJ,
how' they ever get mad at Hassan? That's literally his exact
position on the Houthies. If you're criticizing me and I don't
think you care about the genocide, you're just distracting from
it. You're criticizing the Houthies, you I won't disavow them.
I'll stand 10 toes down. But then when he's like not getting
pressured, he'll go, "Yeah, I don't think kidnapping civilians
is bad." And >> right, it's the exact same position. How
do you even criticize it? >> You're literally you just
ape that exact >> I don't even hate that position personally.
I I don't totally hate that. Like the idea that you don't give
that ground to conservatives in conversation, it's not it's not
the worst. >> I think it comes down to it's one of those
things where you have to be so you have to socially understand
the situation you're in. And sometimes it could be good and sometimes
it could be bad cuz there will be times where if you don't do
it, if you're like getting asked by Piers Morgan and you've got
a bunch of other people there and all they're going to talk about
is that for the next 20 minutes, your refusal to disavow, right?
Then I think that could be somewhere you should disavow. But
if it's like a one-on-one with Ethan, maybe you don't. I'm not
totally sure. It seems to work pretty badly for me most of the
time. >> Yeah, I think it's just about uh like different
standards there. I just thought it was funny that I just realized
that that's like, oh, they're just using the exact argument he
did and all the clips generated from it that they're going to
say are being disingenuous disingenuously used to cancel them
are like the same clips that are being used to cancel Hassan,
like the best ones. It's very weird.
Yeah. Anyway, I >> literally Destiny can't have an issue
with that Tom Cotton tweet under this logic at all. That Tom
Cotton tweet is just I think that Tom Cotton tweet is awesome
anyway. I sp that anyway cuz like I don't think it is like an
imminent call to violence in any way. I don't think anyone would
Tom Tom would do hickey if they were >> Oh, you're talking
about the Han the Han >> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Destiny literally can't call that out anymore. Destiny can't
condemn that cuz it's literally Tom Cotton is you know using
violent rhetoric. He's saying do do what you can or whatever.
Do whatever you have to do to get these practice out.
>> Yep. And replies with with a doohickey.
>> Anyway, that tweet's awesome. Anyway, I totally spot
that tweet regardless, but Destiny certainly can't condemn it.
Now, >> uh I think if you're So, I'm of like a couple different
minds on the political violence stuff, but if you're on the table
or if you're on the side of okay, the the pot's boiling is boiling
over and all of these influencers are adding more to it and that
needs to stop then then like I don't know. You have to call it
all of it. You can't just call it Han and not the other people,
which is what I see a lot of right now. I see. Dude, how is tomorrow's
got to be crazy with that tweet? Because they're using a three-year-old
Hassan tweet where he's talking about a debate, like gutting
people in a debate, and Destiny just straight up came out was
like, "No, I love that these people are scared. They need to
be more scared." Actually, how does he escape like whatever Dan's
cancellation machine? >> Dude, the the crazy one is bad
and pad disavowed the violence and Destiny didn't like >> No
way. No way. >> Yeah, let me be post. Wait, no. Let Let
me send you the this
>> I was talking about this the other day. Um he's like
banned a bunch of people in his community for arguing this is
like a good move. This is like good strategy or >> I going
to play on this. See what this
>> Comment as well. >> Okay. Yeah. Yeah. >> Whether
you choose violence or not. Violence is coming to you. You either
fight back or you die. You either fight back or you die.
>> Destiny and Elon Musk. Two sides of the same coin. You
have two wolves inside of
Okay, violence is coming for you guys. >> The truth
>> today, Elon, I think we're I think the British public
are telling the world that they're ready to fight back.
>> Come on. Come on.
>> This guy,
>> bro. You see he's got you see he's got a uh shirt on
that says, "What would Orwell do?" with an eye on it. >> What
would Orwell think? What would Orwell think or think? Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Sorry. Sorry. He had to explain what that shirt was. Nobody
got it. He like opens up and he's like, "Uh, you won't see I'm
wearing I'm wearing a shirt as a a quote from one of your great
authors,
George Orwell." Not a quote where it says it's about one of your
great authors, George Orwell. It's like, okay, no one in the
crowd reads, bro. No one in the crowd is literate. This is like
literally the bottom bottom tier of society.
>> No, no, no, no. He did it again. Come on, Black.
>> They tried to save him by cutting away and they couldn't
do it in time. Oh, no. >> This whole thing is hilarious,
man. >> We've inspired the nation. >> Oh, he's so
>> I've got I've got like so many time stamps if you want
to go over this. >> Yeah, maybe I got to go over this panel,
too. I
>> it's so they have like Okay, there's there's one moment
where they have like
these New Zealanders like Mayori or whatever come out and like
rip up a bunch of flags and they're like in the name of Christ
I I curse secular humanism
and then they rip up a secular humanism flag and they rip up
like every flag they do like an Islamic state flag and they get
to a Palestine flag and they rip that up as well and no Israel
flag nothing about the Jews. It's like, >> well, to be
fair, it's secular humanism. >> Well, yeah, but that's
like so that's tangentially,
you know.
>> Okay. I just I literally the only reason I know that
is because uh people call it a dog whistle. Secular humanist.
>> Yeah. But it it's it's tangentially.
>> It's not directly.
>> Fair enough. >> You know, it doesn't he doesn't
go after Israel in the same way he goes. It's like just so clearly
zed out and like every part of the presentation is like that.
the rally. It's just like endless so they have their walking
around with
>> like flags that are doublesided and they have a St.
George's cross on one side and then the Israeli flag on the other
>> Why? How? How did they Okay, you got to hand it to these
people. How did they take white nationalism and zog it up? How
do you like I feel like that's one of the things >> Robinson
did it somehow.
>> I just I don't get it. Okay, it's nuts. How? I thought
these I thought these people were supposed to be >> It's
just um It's just Well, they hate Muslims, too. >> They
hate Muslims, too. I guess it's maybe only possible in Britain
because of your all of your immigration, right? Like it being
specifically Muslim
>> I think I think it's possible in all of Europe really.
>> Oh, sure, sure, sure. I just met like North America.
I feel like it's a little more difficult cuz the immigration
isn't quite at that level, but it's more of a like imminent or
more propaganda threat in the US in sorry in Europe if not real,
right? Like people >> [__] hilarious as well.
Nigel Farage has been getting death threats on TikTok this week
and so he's in parliament crying about violent rhetoric and how
we shouldn't vilify people or use historical imagery to villainize
people. Like dude, you literally have been saying that we're
getting invaded for the last 10 years. It's so crazy for all
the every time I hear somebody who I know for a fact says Democrats
are like demon spawn or have said those things. Every time they're
like every time they're like, "Oh, you said you said we were
fascists." It's like, "Dude, kill
>> Yeah, I actually killed myself for real. >> I
I'm sorry, but there are a bunch of people on your side who actually
love that label and like proudly wear it, right? There's nobody.
There's nobody who proudly wears pedoph
plays directly to them. >> Yeah. As
>> Sorry. Sorry. Steven Bono always the >> Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Well known, well celebrated.
Let me read this bad empanada message here. It's pinned to one
of his videos here. I've variously seen dozens of you argue that
Charlie Kirk was equivalent to Archduke France Ferdinand, Sar
Nicholas II, and Benjamin Netanyahu. I have banned everyone permanently
because but Jesus Christ, some of you legitimately think that
online creat Oh, that online c online political creators are
running the [__] world. Get a grip on reality. Charlie
Kirk did tip to Tik Tok propaganda and campus debates. He will
be replaced by 500 more. No movement will be dead in the water
as a result of his passing. No government coalition will fall.
There will be no opportunity to seize in its mist in its midst.
The only possible outcome of this is not in anyone's favor except
the right. Some parts of that are true. This is I'm surprised
that he's so disconnected that he doesn't understand Charlie
Kirk's influence. That's a little >> Yeah, true. That's
the downplay of Charlie Kirk's in influence kind of like [__]
but whatever. >> Yeah. Like not not that he can't be replaced.
I think he can be replaced. >> It'll take time. >> Well,
I think TPUSA is an organization that won't falter at all because
of his passing. I don't think TPUSA needs a major like personality
as the founder because I don't think he did a really good job
of making himself a well-known personality in like the first
five plus years of TPUSA existing. Like I think he was kind of
just like a nerdy loser that people mocked. Um, and now he is
far more like celebrated even slightly before his death. Okay,
not quite as much as after his death. After his death, they've
just like 100xed this guy's influence somehow. Like this guy
was actually Jesus. This guy might have been Jesus actually.
I >> All the AI stuff is so funny,
>> dude. The Ted Cruz tweet is crazy.
>> So good. I literally thought that was a joke image when
I first saw it. I was >> I I didn't pull it up because
I was like, "This is offensive." I was like, "This is too I don't
want to pull this up on my stream. It's offensive." It's like
Ted Cruz who posted it, dude. >> It's like literally like
we're already like It's crazy because they treat the people they
like the same as the people they hate. Like this could be like
a mecha droid like a George Droid like you know like George Droid
AI meme or some [__] You could be doing like
[__] cryptocoin scams using images like this and
people would be like a this is the funniest in the world. But
no this is like Ted Cruz is posting this is like yeah this is
awesome propaganda actually. This is going to make people really
uh really feel for the current political moment.
Unfortunately. Unfortunately. Okay. 3.7 million views, 23k likes.
Okay, it might actually be working. We might be the ones who
are wrong here. Okay, this actually does affect the >> lie.
I I think t I'm becoming increasingly convinced that Twitter
is fake that Twitter a lie. >> Could be. It could be. I
think it's like amplification. It's like uh like a lot of the
views and stuff just get amplified for I don't know, not no reason,
but
like the engagement is made up. Like the 23k likes and like I
think
ah there's like bots all over the place liking doing [__]
Boomer Slop AI is the winning ticket now. Dude, Alex Jones's
ads for his are amazing. Have you seen Alex Jones's ads? His
AI ads.
>> He's got like AI ads for his supplements now. Like I
don't know. They're They're crazy. Okay, it's actually wild.
It's like him and AI like fighting swamp monsters for his like
algae pills. It's >> They play like an AI song at that
Tommy Robinson rally that basically just says the 14 words at
one point and flashes up a picture of a bunch of like, you know,
Muslim rapists and then a white girl
>> It's funny, man. It's so funny. >> I had to go
off again today about how like Bosch is actually Do we just trust
Bosch on everything from now on? Bosch is like more powerful
than every tarot card. Like
>> He's like got a crystal ball. Dude, you got to check
this clip out. Okay. >> You think he's just talking completely
out of his ass cuz like he's reading an article that's on screen.
It just like he's not saying what's in the article at all. Like
you think you think this guy's just like narrativeizing. This
guy's just making stuff up. Like Vi is actually reading an article
from like 2 years in the future. He's just uh he's not telling
you. He can't tell you. This it's so crazy like this exact clip
I >> see there are historical
>> I like remember this I was like talking about how Vos
was just right about everything and somebody sent me this >> of
your strategy not working usually when fascist governments begin
to take >> also again I'm going to say this a million times
stop saying fascist stop saying fascist truly in history there
have been like three okay this is like the fascism is like this
biggest boogeyman in the universe okay stop saying fat. We're
not these fascist, bro. There have been like less There's been
like three in all of human history.
>> Yeah. Like, how do you just not How do you not have
to like apologize to this guy for ever doubting him? This guy
This guy defines the future. Okay. I told Extreme Dad was here
earlier. He didn't like this take when I was giving it and I
said, "Yeah, well, you're [__] a kid in like 5 years,
buddy. I hope you understand that." Like, it's he he defined
it. Okay. He saw it coming. He predicted your future. I'm sorry.
Uh Bosch predicted the ear wound. anymore. Sorry, extreme. >> Turns
out this was like a Terminator that came from the future that
was supposed to be a shot that was aimed directly through his
cranium. Okay. And he dodged that. He can't get this guy. >> Okay.
Stop.
Anyway, Jesus. My god,
dude. There is something there, isn't there, Zanekali? Like Bosch
Bosch was signaling to us that he could read the future, right?
Hold on. Find me the CPAC. The Trump CPAC speech with the bandage.
Where is it? This guy could see the future the whole time. Where
is it? Where is it?
Here it is. He's just been taunting us the whole time, guys.
Everybody's like, "What? What the is that bandage?" Oh, the RNC.
Yes, the RNC. What is that bandage that he's wearing for no reason?
He's just like making fun of us that we can't see the future
like he does. Okay. That's all that's happening there.
Oh, crazy
stuff. >> Did you cover the Bron Woo tweet? >> Uh,
no. I think I just sent it to some people that I didn't cover
it. But yeah, I or I laughed about her. Some people in my in
my Discord were like I could understand her being scared right
now. And I'm like, dude, she's been on the internet for so long.
She was actually scared. Why would she be? She knows not to tweet
about it. She's just doing it's like this is her default position.
She could like virtue signal right now on some she's going to
do it.
>> Oh, let me go find it. I saw you I saw you had a tweet
take off that was just a picture of it. I thought about doing
the same thing. I was like I wanted to tweet and just like laugh
at her tweet. >> Yeah, I saw Harmful's reply. I can't remember
it now. Where is it? S.
Sorry, I'm laughing at the >> Charlie is lying. Yeah. >> Yeah.
I am a trans woman. I am not violent. I do not like guns. I have
a job. I've been married monogously for 17 years and I love our
country. Please don't hurt me. I have nothing to do with this
atrocity.
This is just the weirdest.
Anyway, crazy before and afters. Can hardly tell Brianna used
to be Chinese.
God. Yeah. I don't know why she did this. Every time I leave
my house alone at night by myself, it's uh
Dude,
I I
mural, man. Dude, oh my god. >> Oh, the Charlie Kirk mural.
>> Yeah. I didn't pull that up on stream because I'm trying
to not I was trying to be like a little bit more a little bit
less, you know, all about Israel for like the first couple days
of the Charlie Kirk thing. So, I didn't want to lean into the
thing lean into like the Netanyahu conspiracies. Where are you
at on that? Cuz it feels like >> I just watched an InfoWars
video and it was pretty convincing, I got to say. Like I don't
know if I'm convinced, but like I I am convinced that like big
time is really money was probably like kind of ped him right
for being a part of some of the conversations about Epstein and
I could believe that. I don't know if I believe they got him
killed. I just don't I don't think I don't know. Yeah, I don't
I don't necessarily believe they got him killed or anything.
Oh, also came out today that the shooter is not cooperating with
the cops,
which I don't understand.
>> The governor came out and said, "Oh, uh the shooter's
not cooperating with us." But I thought he turned himself in.
Oh, we didn't get turned in. >> No, I thought I thought
basically it was his dad he told his dad. His dad told the family
friend. The family friend came over and convinced him to turn
himself in. They he went and surrendered himself to the law enforcement
there. But I don't know why you turn yourself in and then say,
"I'm also not cooperating." Probably because they've been saying
they want they will go for the death penalty the whole time.
So, he doesn't want them to help them execute him.
Yeah, fair enough. So, Frenzy Freeze, this was reported at first,
but I thought it's now been reported that it was his uh like
his dad.
Yeah, I think this is what it is, Sherry. I think um I think
it's that they want him to snitch on the people he was talking
to about it beforehand. If there are people he was talking to
about it beforehand, I think they want him to give up those people
and he's probably not willing. Okay, I've read different 42XX,
but is this up to date? CBS News article.
Second, we pull this. Where is this at? CBS News suspect arrested
in Charlie Kirk September 12th.
I've seen this reported multiple different ways. That's the weird
thing.
>> what an idiot. Tell his dad. >> What a [__]
idiot. >> Dude, I can't believe how funny every world event
is now. It doesn't even matter if it's like a universally tragic
world event. Like nothing else. Nothing else. Oh yeah. Okay.
I People have been telling me you've been being gay about
And I'm I'm worried. This isn't >> Oh, you just want to
laugh at Charlie Kirk. Yeah, it's fine. I I think it's sad that
he died. Yeah. >> Oh my god.
>> Yeah, it's fine. We don't have to talk about it. But
I just think it's hilarious that we get like all the Cash Fel
memes. See you in Valhalla, brother. Like this. I heard him say
that while I was watching it, watching the press conference that
morning and I I I couldn't believe he said it. Like the what
what is he? He's like He's Hindu. He's Hindu. He's not even Christian.
He's Hindu. He's not Christian or like some pagan. He's Hindu.
>> Here's a ratchet. Like Hinduism is paganism. No, there's
a lot of gods. >> Different kind of paganism. Sure. Sure.
>> Technically, not that kind of pagan. Uh,
you guys disagree on something big, but it's not a position that
you can like argue. It's like how you feel morally about making
fun of somebody getting shot in the neck. I'm not like out here
saying I, by the way, I don't I think it's like wrong to laugh
at. Like I not wrong. I I feel bad about it. I don't like it.
But um it's like, dude, I'm thinking about starting to joke about
it because of Asmin Gold's campaign. Like I think I'm actually
morally compelled to stand up like I'm Spartacus, okay? Or in
the place of Spartacus.
>> Like they can't they can't all of us, okay? They can't
cancel all of us. >> The moment I saw the video and then
the ne the first thing I I read about it was someone entertaining
the idea that he might be alive, I knew it was going to be incredibly
funny, >> dude. Uh Tim Pool on Twitter, guys. I'm hearing
from sources that Charlie Kirk is alive and stable. It's like,
uh-huh.
>> that's that's classic Tim Pool reporting right there.
Do Hindus have something about not mentioning the Christian heaven
or was he just trying to freestyle some white references? So,
from what I understand, that's funny to me. He's just like doesn't
get it. He just throws out like a Norse thing cuz he thinks all
white people like believe in that. That's funny. But uh what
I actually think it is is uh cops have there's like this weird
like overlap between cop culture and white supremacy.
Uh what do they call it? Like uh operator culture or something.
It's like this cop culture white supremacist overlap that they
do like uh Viking rune tattoos and
there's like a lot of Viking laring in law enforcement and that's
probably what he was doing. Yeah. Yeah. Anyway, what else we
got here? I'm going back to this panel eventually. I would check
this out. Um, maybe I'll go check out your stream, see what was
good in this. I will check this out. I think it would be good
content for tomorrow.
I kind of want to finish up my the panel here. Did you have What
did you think? What's your what's your like take on this? It's
like you got to be prepared for some kind of civil war. Is that
where you're at? Or
>> uh Yeah. I think if you're American staying in America,
you need to prepare some kind of civil war. Yeah. >> I
don't think it goes to civil war. I think it goes more to like
um desperate decentralized terrorism, right? Which most people
don't participate in. I think that's that's most likely the case,
but you should probably still be entertaining the idea. >> I
don't think a civil war can happen. >> Even if it's not
going to be an allout civil war, you should be ready for the
idea that you might be attacked.
>> Sure. I don't I just don't think there I think there's
a lot of people who are like pretty checked out of politics that
just won't be a part of that and won't
>> Yeah, but it doesn't take like a huge amount of the
country being like giga violent. It just takes like a some amount
that's being sort of >> turned a blind eye to by the government,
right? I I don't think that you can get very large scale political
violence in the United States actually. Like I'm not even I'm
not even joking. I think um
I think the surveillance state there is like way too powerful.
Like I don't think you can get people I think >> assuming
that the government wants to stop it, right? You're assuming
that government that there there's a will to stop it. What if
>> Well, that's No, but that's more the problem. Yes. is
is that would be my only concern is does Trump want to but Trump
will want to stop it but he he'll only want to stop like half
of it right like there will be busts okay of like radical leftist
like bomb- making factories or something like there will be busts
okay
but >> no I don't even mean that what if Sam Hyde is trying
to get people to go for a race war right now what if a group
start doing that is stronger want to stop that
>> yeah I think though.
>> You really think? Okay.
>> Yeah. Benjamin Netanyahu needs this economy to keep
running, we're safe. As long as Israel needs the United States,
we're safe. >> It depends on his base react. I think >> I
don't know. You are not American. Actually, neither of us are
American. That's why we can see this clearly.
>> Non-Americans are actually far better talking about
American politics than Americans. This is like day one knowledge.
This >> is facts. I really just do be that way.
man, I'm I think like probably the arming up thing is is fine.
I think it's like desperate violence that's pretty difficult
to see how it would work.
>> The thing is so like if you thought, you know, if people
thought car bombs were bad, wait till people are strapping to
drones. Okay. Yeah, but drones are way No, I think I don't think
you can get that because I think I think there's like um like
anti- electronic warfare stuff that's going to make drones like
pretty difficult to do with. And somebody was pointing out earlier
though that apparently they banned import of drones to like like
private Hold on. Trump drones law. What just got passed? Something
just got passed. I feel like something just happened where they're
like actually trying to restrict drone ownership. Am I crazy?
>> Yeah, I can imagine why. Yeah, but I mean that that
seems like they're looking forward to that, right? Chinese drone
imports. Wait, did they cut off Chinese drone imports? Because
I thought they were trying to import Chinese drones. I know they've
signed executive orders trying to ramp up drone production in
the US as well. Stock up on fiber spool drones. Well, that's
what you would need, right? You need stuff that can't get jammed
and you need stuff that can't get like knocked out of the air
by electronic warfare. But even
>> drones are not even talking but I'm not even talking
about like if you're going to full out war with the government.
I'm talking about like you're saying desperate terrorist attacks
like you could still now probably with
consumer drones commit some pretty horrific by just getting a
drone into place that you shouldn't have it. >> Yeah. Like
how safe is you know if you if you can get an explosive on a
drone how safe is like any individual you can you can ultimately
you can just fly to someone's mansion and while they're in their
bedroom and blow up next to [__] mansion right
by the
>> I think you I think you actually need to drop pretty
accurately for like the grenade drones that um consumer like
consumer drones could actually fly around like I don't I don't
think you can hit somebody in their house. I don't think that
would really be possible.
Um,
right. Cuz you need a certain size of explosive and I don't think
I think those drones had to land pretty direct hits to actually
kill people. >> You really think you don't think you'd
get someone at a window?
they'd have to be like Yeah. outside of the window basically
and you'd have to drop it and not hit like the roof or some [__]
and have it explode on the roof. Like you you could do damage,
but I don't think like I've seen people survive direct hits from
those grenades. Now they survive cuz they're bleeding out internally.
But like I think if those grenades don't hit pretty directly,
they actually don't necessarily kill people. Like it'll still
be terrorism, right? You even if you hit somebody's house without
killing them, that's still going to like amp up massively. I
just think of
like Israel did this to Russia, right? That that is a question
I remember getting contemplated by people of like what's um what's
the US's readiness for that level of domestic terrorist attack?
Like is did you see those videos of Israel like flying the uh
sorry they had the semi-truckss the yeah like the the what would
you call like long haul trucks fil like the beds were filled
with drones and they just went and took out like a bunch of Russian
was it like Russian air force assets. Russia lost like 600 million
or $700 million in air force assets.
>> You kept saying Israel. You mean >> Oh yeah, Ukraine
did this. Wait. >> Yeah. Yeah. >> Yeah. Ukraine did
this. Yeah. I don't know why I said Israel. Wait, no. Israel
did this as well. Israel did this as well. Sorry, they both did
it. That's why I'm confused. >> Isra No, Israel did it
to Iran, I believe. I believe Israel had like a Yeah. Yeah. Israel
did this to Iran. They like had
Dude, they went crazy. They had like a like a drone produ production
factory sitting in Iran. Israel also destroyed a Russian base.
Wait, did they really? >> Well, yeah, the Ukraine [__]
anyway. That's that's crazy. And obviously, you know, I thought
the fear more so was like the idea of like China or someone having
the ability to like, you know, if they've got like some facility
where they can just put a bunch of drones in a truck with a bunch
of fiber optic cables attached to it, they could just
from from inside the US, one attack on a military base. Do about
it >> cuz it's like how many military bases are there with
like, you know, 2 miles away, you've got like open parking that
somebody could just park a truck there and start launching drones.
Yeah. I'm just looking through Kio Crane just showed. Yeah. Well,
I think the difference I think is with US military assets like
their ships and stuff. I think the electronic defense systems
on those ships are really sophisticated and I don't think anything
remotely commercial grade gets through them. Right. Uh the fiber
optics cable thing full of hell is how Ukraine was dealing with
jamming from Russian stuff was they just had like big spools
of fiber optic cable that would attach to the drone and it's
so light that the drone just it just goes and then it's like
by the time you're close enough it's just like locked on and
it doesn't need any communications to it anymore. Anyway, we're
way off topic. I don't even know what the topic is actually.
Drone stuff's pretty scary. All right, I'm probably going to
get back to this. I'm trying to think of like I don't know. Do
you have any like prescriptions for I I feel like if you're an
online influencer, you should probably just be universally calling
for violence. Not even because that's like your actual position,
but it's like it's just automatically like the game theoretical
optimal position to take. Like it even if it's not enough that
you like don't think you should um
and it doesn't it also doesn't mean I think you just disavow
the violence alone. And you could even say like the other side
pushes it way more. Like you could you could include any conditionals
you want. You just have to say like obviously all violence has
to stop.
That's like what you should be doing. I don't know. Did you have
any disagreements with that? >> Um
I mean it just depends what you mean by that. You should definitely
say the words I condemn political violence in all forms or something
like that. You should definitely say those words. >> I
think you should also like
And I I think it's okay to say like obviously there's somebody
who's like amping up this kind of violence or this kind of rhetoric.
Like I I don't think you have to like um like lie about, you
know, it's both sides doing it and both sides need to stop. I
don't think you need to say that. I just think you need to make
it clear that like Yeah, it has to stop.
Like every case it has to stop. Yeah. Anyway, I'm going to listen
to more of this insanity. >> I mean, the issue my only
problem is is like you're saying it has to stop, but like I don't
want Do you really want part of the message that like it's always
always bad?
Because it's like I mean, at some point it's going to not be
bad. at some point, you know, if if she goes too far, it's like,
okay, no should get pretty crazy. Like, if if the midterms are
rigged or >> I think you wait for I think you wait to get
there.
>> The message Yeah. Yeah. The message right now should
not be this like >> guys, political violence is literally
so bad that you should never even entertain the idea of it. No,
you should probably think about it. But it is really bad and
this is really bad and this shouldn't have happened. If your
democracy gets taken away from you, then you have to.
Sure, you could. I mean, that's obviously true, but I'm just
trying to think of like
how appropriate is it like right there. What did you think the
MSNBC guy getting >> I didn't even look into it. I haven't
seen any name, but Don Lemon, was it? >> I don't think
it was I don't know if it was Don Lemon. It was some old guy.
No, it was some old guy. Wasn't Don Lemon. >> I thought
I thought I heard that name. I thought I had that name. >> Maybe
Don Lemon did get fired from somewhere else, but the MSNBC guy
was some old white guy. He was just He was basically like,
what do you say? like Donald Trump has pushed us here. He like
Yeah, Dodd. Okay. Dowed
>> he said some something like like we've been pushed here
by Trump. Oh no, no, no. He also said Charlie's rhetoric pushed
it here. And he basically said like something along the lines
of like play stupid games, win stupid prizes.
>> And it's like ah
like while that is possibly true, that's probably the worst possible
time to utter that phrase. Like I'm not shocked you got let go.
Like I just you don't you probably just don't ponder certain
questions at certain certain moments in time if you're
you know economically challenged. Where's his job under that?
Yeah, it's pretty >> Some uh the same artist was ching
de death to the IDF at Glastenbury in the UK was just uh celebrating
Charlie K's death in Amsterdam
and uh people were like oh you celebrate Charlie G's death and
he was like no no I didn't buy me the quote where I celebrated
Charlie G's death. It's just like a video of him going like I
don't I don't know how to describe it but it's it's like this
one goes out to Charlie Kirk. Uh chit get banged and he does
a gun for this hand. It's like okay man.
Jesus Christ. Why did he Wait, why did he say people really be
like that sometimes? Find me a clip of me doing that and it's
like a thing they proudly >> So I just send you I send
you the literally here it is. Here's the clip from him ask people
to present him the clip and then in the replies obviously is
the clip
>> hold on see this >> yo real quick at no point
during yesterday's show was Charlie Kirk's death celebrated
at no point whatsoever did we celebrate Charlie Kirk's death.
Uh I did call him a piece of [__] That much is true.
Um but at no point was his death
If it was, go find me a quote. Go find me something that proves
that we were >> Hold on real quick. Okay, I just have to
address this comments. Well, to me that the MSNBC guy gets fired,
but the Fox guy calling for the homeless and mentally ill to
be involuntarily lethal injected is not. He just had to apologize
after saying just kill them. Uh, that should tell you something
about the public outrage and where the public's at on the the
homeless population. But sure, it could be in terms of the wrongness
of those statements. Maybe I'm just telling you that's uh where
the public's at. Okay. >> His death.
You're not going to find it because it didn't happen. Uh what
did happen is one reporter that bought their ticket online came
with the sole purpose of finding something to report and after
I called him a piece of [__] and we played a song.
Um they have written that up as a celebration. Not a celebration.
Isn't a celebration. wasn't a celebration. Um, calm down, you
know, real quick.
>> The pronouns
>> Hold on. He could save it. He could save it. Give him
a second. Let him cook.
>> That didn't make it better. Hold on.
>> Charlie, you piece of [__]
>> Can we Can we cancel him for a facial expression? Certainly
looks like he's >> really smile. Really smiling is a problem
now. Really?
>> Really? Yeah. Kill a man for smiling. You got this guy
for smiling. >> Is it crazy? Is it crazy to say that this
seems like giddiness? Possibly.
>> You know, lynch a black man for a bit of whimsy. Really?
Is that lynching black men for whimsy? >> I love that he's
like there's nothing there you couldn't possibly say. Did he
say that wasn't celebrating? Yes. He's like, find me a clip of
me celebrating Charlie Kirk's death. He's literally dancing.
He's literally dancing. This
>> that's based. I care. That's awesome.
>> That's literally what the MSAD agents were doing when
the September 11th towers went down that was like this this precise
jig right here. All right.
>> I I I just believe that's celebrating.
>> That's just That is celebrating.
>> It's awesome. It's awesome to do. It's just awesome
to do the clip where you say, "Yeah, I didn't do that." That
five quote will be doing that when you know full well that's
exactly what you did.
>> H
that's wild. Watch if I ever bump into >> Okay, Tommy.
Dude, this guy's literally got about three feet on Tommy. What
the is this guy saying? Steven Yaxi Land and ching the comments.
>> Dude, it's a who's who? Tommy Robinson, Gad, and Paul
Joseph Watson. You called him a piece of >> Oh, yeah. There
there's also a video people caught uh Tommy Robinson ordering
for a drug dealer
>> while he was at the pub after or before the rally. >> Yeah,
I'm sure >> literally he's l
to his catch on video. He's talking to his phone saying, "Yeah,
more gear, bro." >> Someone link it. Someone's got to link
it right now. >> I think I play somewhere.
>> Hutch is Hutch is breaking the conditioning. Okay, >> Hutch
is breaking the conditioning. >> It's not good. It's not
good. He's uh he's gotten he's gotten harassed like all day.
Literally the whole day was just him being like I think I think
calling for violence is bad and people being like >> I
think you're probably not being particularly pragmatic here when
you're like supporting this unhinged freak thing. Crazy stuff.
>> Did you watch that food shops >> I watched like
half of it. Yeah. >> Why did Why did Dest pick somebody
to raid who's like literally incapable of >> Yeah. Mentally
[__] Legit mentally
>> I think what's happening, listen, I can string two thoughts
together, okay? I think what's happening with food shops is they're
actually just reading comments and taking arguments from their
chat and not able to connect them together and realize because
there's multiple times where they concede their entire argument
without realizing it. >> The the argument changes so much
as well. First is it's like Destiny's actual position which is
yeah violence is based which is an actual position if you you
know are not 70 IQ and are capable of reading through the lines
in any way. Uh and it starts off with that and then it ends being
oh no I just think that if you're on Pierers Morgan and there's
a bunch of conservatives there in that one case you shouldn't
disavow violence. Okay.
You're saying nothing there. >> Uhhuh. Oh,
dude. I think Hutch I think the only reason Hutch even gave them
that one, by the way, was cuz he felt bad at that point. I was
like, I'll just not really respond to that. Like, he just kind
of was like, okay, this person doesn't know what they're talking
about. >> You have to listen close in this clip to what
he says.
>> Okay, hold on. What's this?
>> Nope. Hold on.
>> Have you got I can't hear his voice. I can't discern
his voice from the crowd. Hold on, dude.
I can't discern more gear, bro.
>> I can't hear him at all.
>> I literally can't hear him at all. That's crazy.
>> More gear. More beer.
>> Why? Why would he be saying more beer down into his
phone below the table? >> No idea. >> He's He's saying
he's saying more gear,
I just >> I'm sorry, but why would is it who is this
I can't believe that people would want this clip to like show
that he's like dude the guy's just always been on like his entire
career. There's literally not a single person who's like this
guy doesn't do who know who doesn't know they're lying like through
their >> Well, it's just funny that you know it's just
good to show that he's doing it right when he's doing the rallies.
You know, this is just a bunch of degenerate alcoholic cokeheads
like lazy
laborers and degenerate leadrained scum
that you just go out there to get in fights and act racist. >> Yeah,
but anybody who that's not convincing anybody either though.
It's funny.
Yeah, you know that everybody who who everybody who cares already
knows >> that that >> there's like nothing you can
do. Yeah, but I'm not trying to convince those
>> you know. No, I'm not trying to convince these people.
You need to convince these
>> you make these people look stupid and bad. They are.
What's >> this? We got another We got another quote here.
Hold on. What is this?
>> Kirk show. Kirk show
of hosting the Charlie Kirk show. Please join me as I pay tribute
to my friend. >> Yeah, I don't know if you saw that JD
Vance hosting. >> Is it true that Ben used to defend >> Used
what? to defend Israel. >> Apparently, he hosted the episode
today or something and was like defending Israel on it. >> I
mean,
I can't imagine that being false. I literally everything I've
seen Ben Shapiro do in his entire career leads me to believe
that would be the
You know what I mean? Like, it's just like, do you hear that?
Why
do like, "Yeah, we're going to we're going to just >> we're
going to just uh" >> Well, apparently Netanyahu Netanyahu
jumped on what was it? Uh >> Newsmax or whatever
to just full on deny. It's like, "Bro, what what >> they're
like, I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry I even have to ask you
this question. I'm sorry. It's such a stupid question. I'm sorry
I have to ask a stupid question. It's such such a stupid question.
It's such crazy people saying this. You You didn't You didn't
kill Charlie Kirk, did you?" >> Wild. Oh no, that's ridiculous.
That's ridiculous. That's ridiculous. >> I would never
>> I would never I can't even say this joke, I think, because
I will get FBI. He's definitely gonna say it.
Do you like if the I never don't no violence. I never [__]
I can't actually I can't even make the joke. Wait, hold on. I'm
turning this into DG. I This is a good joke. Hold on. Let me
throw. That's way too edgy, right?
>> I almost find it funny. But like listen, it's uh it's
funny from multiple directions because I'm just hoping that somebody
is sending this all to the Trump campaign or the Trump White
House. Like it's funny from this direction. I can like I go,
okay, that's a little funny. But uh I just really laughing from
the uh end where it's like, >> look, this guy is such a
larer. I'm sick of him talking about violence all the time. He's
got all those guns. Come on, let's uh >> That's what I
That's what I said earlier today. If you're going to keep saying
that violence is necessary, these people need to be scared. Well,
time to stop time to stop talking about firebombing McDonald's.
Okay. >> Less canvasing, more militia, less cam less doornocking,
more firing range. >> I thought you guys were good at
>> Yeah, for real. Where's your ground >> This is
what Conor meant. Okay. Connor was also seeing the future. He's
like, these guys can really organize. He was just making sure
he doesn't get shot the upcoming Civil War. Okay. Keeping his
options open.
Ain't too edgy, right? That's I think that's less edgy, by the
way. That's like more obviously a joke. less edgy than the uh
I want these people scared comment. There's a Hutch's response
to it. By the way, in what universe is the MAGA movement ever
in a million years going to going to their leadership and asking
them to turn the temperature down after conservative is murdered?
Yeah. I just I think there's like I don't I just don't understand
how it's like asking Japan. You nuke Japan and then you're like,
can you guys turn the temperature down a little bit? Can you
Can you turn the I need you guys to turn the temperature down.
Like, yeah, I think they think it's time to be like, I don't
know, a little magnanimous. Maybe a little little magnanimous,
but alas. Oh, K up. Kton, I don't care. I think Republicans are
worse people than Democrats. I think, listen, I just think Martin
Luther King had a point, okay? I just think Martin Luther King
was like a visionary leader who had a point about using your
dignity um as like a weapon, right? I just I just think Martin
Luther King was cool. I I find it weird, you know, DJ is totally
denigrating the memory of Martin Luther King. God bless. Okay.
Me personally, I I think uh a path of nonviolence is the way.
But trust me, when you when you're out there, okay,
make sure you tag us, K Captain. What whatever you got planned,
make sure you tag this channel, okay? Let me know. I I don't
want to miss it. Drugs and opinion is invalid. No, I think his
opinion was better, actually. Better for that. MLK did more Coke
than Tommy Robinson. Sure. >> That's not true. That's not
true. >> I Oh, there's no way that's true. That's not
true. >> I'm just willing to say that he's still awesome.
Even if that were the case, he agrees with your point. >> No,
there's literally no way that's >> Captain Cappy Pants,
that's what I said. Civility politics for the Palestinians. Okay,
you guys need to show dignity. You guys can't be violent. You
guys need to show dignity. But for for everybody else, no, no,
no. It's civil war time, guys. Actually, that Trump guy is really
mean. And I know one of your guys just got shot, but I will not
disavow the violence. Palestinians. Okay, Hassan. Hassan needs
to disavow the violence. Disavow October. Will you disavow?
Will you disavow?
Can you just disavow? Amazing. Amazing stuff. Visionary stuff.
Yeah, I made that point earlier today. Cap Captain Cappy Pants.
Oh boy.
I just think it's cool that Hutch is breaking the conditioning.
It's unfortunate that I'm blocked by him on Twitter. We'll never
be able to interact with him, but the president could at least
lead by example. No, he couldn't. Your president is a Your president
is a lesser human being. Okay? Your president is subhuman. He
can't lead by example. He's incapable. If he was capable of leading
by example, he would have done it at any point in his entire
tenure. If you're willing to just because you have a president
burn down your entire country, you're [__] >> Someone
just commented on one of my videos. Uh, did you enjoy watching
a rightwing like yourself get one theft? Real people did. >> Damn.
Do you think that was a person? >> Well, you think it's
a bot.
>> Well, I just don't know. Like honestly, um
the unfortunate reality seems to be that for most of the people
that comment on YouTube videos online, like bots are just more
intelligent and more worthy of like consideration as something
that shouldn't be eliminated than most of the people who comment
already on YouTube videos, which is like a sad reality that we're
living in. Yeah. I think Hutch breaking the conditioning is funny.
I also think it's funny that Hutch had a whole day of people
coming in to argue with him and in his chat like into his Discord
food shops. When did that happen when we were criticizing him?
I can't remember
that ever happened. I didn't think so.
>> No, when when we criticize him, he just gets like doxed
and ripped to death. So, >> apparently God. Okay. I shouldn't
I shouldn't. Dude, the Kagu's top gal guy kind of ruined for
me a little bit. I didn't I didn't realize um I didn't realize
how like much of a s for Fentes they were >> how brown
he is. >> he's just very brown.
Uh maybe, but no,
it's just like him totally supporting all the doxing kind of these
posts
>> kind of ruined it for me overall. See Pixie fighting.
Oh, wait. Did you see Lauren de Lagona and Action Man
>> No.
No, I don't think so.
>> It's kind of funny. But Lauren de Laguna went to go
hang out with Action Man and then he didn't answer the door.
She got really mad and then she went to his house and he called
the cops. Then she talked to the cops. I don't know. That's That's
the long and short of it. Oh, hold on. We got a We I forgot we
had a Chris Pratt update. Ready for Chris Pratt. Chris Chris
Pratt
>> Chris Pratt's political statement. I'm here for it.
Where is it? Where is it? I had it here. It's
here. It is. What is this? >> Guys, just stop real quick
and pray with me. Lord, you say, "Be still and know that I am
God." Psalm 46:10.
Be still and know that I am God. In this moment, please Lord,
calm my restless mind,
quiet my anxious heart. Help me set aside distractions
and
choose what gives life and gives peace. Isaiah 26:3, keep in
perfect peace those whose minds are stayed on you, Lord. Fill
me with strength
to turn my attention toward you that I find rest and joy in your
presence. Amen. Okay,
now you can continue strolling or you can turn your phone off
and go outside.
Might I suggest the ladder? Go get some sunshine. Go look at
a tree, touch some grass, call a friend.
If you've got time to be on your phone right now, you've got
time to do your to-do list and you've got time to reach out to
somebody in need. Share this prayer with them. >> Christian
doing Christian things to be expected. Listen, he he totally
didn't he didn't take uh he didn't try to wakeboard on Charlie
Kirk's corpse. Okay, I can appreciate it. I can appreciate it.
That's the bar for me. All of these people who the Oh, did you
see Dave Rubin? Did you see Dave Rubin try to use Charlie Kirk's
corpse as like a blade against Ch? >> I saw I saw him on
Facebook and playing clips out of his phone. Yeah,
>> dude. And the clip, dude, the clip starts. We went and
looked at the real version of the clip. The clip literally starts
with with Chen going, "Yeah, I categorically like disavow all
violence or whatever." It's like clearly not him calling for
any violence at all and Dave Rubin like has to cut the first
3 seconds off so that he could try to paint Piers. Sorry, Chank
is like calling for violence. Dude,
I feel like that's if they want to cancel people, okay, go for
people like that. Like, why would you get that guy
>> None of it's honest. What do you mean it's not honest?
They're actually upset about people mocking Charlie Kirk's death.
They're just using it as a weapon cuz they want to they think
it's a pretext to actualize more radical beliefs that they hold
like that. That's the whole thing. None of >> Dave No,
Dave Rubin's just making money. Dave Rubin doesn't have real
beliefs. Dave Rubin doesn't for money. >> Okay. Sure. Yeah.
Dave Dave Rubin's part of the machine that's doing this and they're
all part of it and they're all sitting just telling the exact
same lie at all times. You think that machine's explicit or or
just it's like literally extremist people. People have like way
more extreme views than can be expressed properly and so like
a machine has grown that allows those views to be expressed in
the world without criticism that facing criticism.
>> I don't understand what you're saying. as in is this
being directed by somebody by like like are conservatives actually
paying for this like like billionaire conservatives in some way
or is it more of like people had these beliefs they were being
suppressed by like social media and a bunch of other things and
somehow like organically this grew up as something people would
pay for something people would donate to and watch. I just I
feel like it's way more of the second one where it's like people
probably had these beliefs, they felt like they wanted to express
them and they were being like criticized for expressing them
and so people who like gave them some plausible deniability or
way to express those beliefs without feeling like total re they
like started paying them started funding that group of people.
So like it's a kind of populist decentralized movement. Um, I
think that would make sense if the prescriptions that they come
to
made sense with the problems they're claiming,
but it's not. It's like like it's it's like black people are
really annoying, so we need to get rid of the Department of >> Okay.
Is that mostly the DEI thing? >> It might It's like DEI.
It's like
um Yeah, like CRT. That's That's what >> Yeah. Well, I
mean, they're not really same thing. Same.
Yeah. Yeah. It's the same bucket. Woke stuff. It's all about
woke stuff, right? Woke is like the the ultimate weapon. Do whatever
you want.
>> Any institution.
>> Like the fact is it's like actually depressing cuz like
I swear to God I have like some anti-DI beliefs and I'm slowly
realizing that I'm the only person who just didn't want to say
the hard R. Like like everybody else was just like really missing
the time where they could like say the hard R and get away with
it. It's like like I actually think like racism was actually
underlying a lot of that stuff in a way that it it was so much
more
it was so much more lying through all of it than I wanted to
admit or wanted to dude it's it's so like a lot of it I think
that's what I'm realizing more and more is people just realized
that like they didn't want to be persecuted for their beliefs
and so
>> yeah their beliefs are manifesting in a way that's like
somehow t like that's somehow like giving them the outlet for
those beliefs but also not directly saying the things they want
to say so they have plausible deniability. I think that's how
a lot of these like a lot of these movements have kept going
like I I think that's how what would I say I don't know somebody
like Tim Pool exists still Steven Crowder these people it's quite
frustrating remember the racism at the start of Kamal's run Kamla's
run um not quite so bad but yeah sure the um what was it that
she wasn't actually black I think um was Laura Loomer is trying
to prove that she wasn't actually black with Kamala Di's a substitute
it's like a lot of stuff like that chabby, but it's I don't know.
It's it's like you wonder how people get to these really nonsensical
opinions. And I think it comes from like they had basically people
found the like the counter to bigotry. And so the the counter
counter to to it was making your beliefs or making the things
you go for like nonsensical, like arguing for things in the most
indirect way. I don't know. Yeah. I'm trying to I'm trying to
like I need to think about this more like how I see it.
But it's like you're you're doing this really really really um
you're doing like an adjacent parallel argument, but not the
one you actually want to do, but it's one you can defend. It's
like how the how do I defend, you know, how do I defend not wanting
immigrants? I don't want I want like people who look different
than me in my country.
Well, you know, they're like trafficking kids over the border.
Actually, I'm really concerned about um how they're trafficking
kids over the border. That's what I'm going to say. I'm really
really concerned about kid tra kids getting trafficked. Okay,
that's what I'm most concerned about. It's like that's not actually
what your position is. It's not what you're actually concerned
about at all. Anyway, yeah, basically that's what I'm trying
to say. They give you a way to feel racist but feel like an intellectual.
It's Yeah, but people like can't understand or don't fathom that
like the arguments are nonsensical.
That's where it breaks down for me. It's like um I don't know,
a lot of the arguments are totally nonsensical.
They just don't make any sense at all. your culture being >> [__]
killing of the Zeriska or whatever where it's just like the moment
you actually look into the story, it's just like so the the take
is just so obvious and everyone is just like desperate to say,
"Oh yeah, this guy should be put down like a dog." Yeah, he was
just like killing people like this. Is that okay? >> The
take So I've heard what arrested 14 times. I'm guessing that's
14 charges over a couple different arrests, right? >> Yeah,
it's like it's like it was Yeah, it's like violence. He had like
violent uh offenses like 10 to 15 years ago
charged for. Right.
>> Uh no found guilty of >> he did I think he I think
he did did time in jail I think. And then >> yeah he did
for the violent ones >> and then Yeah. Yeah. I think so.
But it's like felonies or something. It's either violence or
felonies. And then then a few years pass he's in another altercation
with his sister. Uh but he doesn't get I don't think she presses
charges on that. Um, and then a few years later, it's like right
before he, you know, you know, a few months ago, it's like it's
like a nuisance 911 call. It's like, okay, so you really think
that that nuisance 911 call should have been the moment he was
put down or like what are we really saying here? >> Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. The nuisance 911 call is like the the thing about
it is like he basically got he said something that was concerning
and it's like maybe that needed to be filtered into some system
that could help him, >> but it was like talking about how
he wasn't capable for his actions or something, right? It's like
wow we if you know we need bare mental health services that if
someone calls the cops and says the government just delivered
them a device that is controlling all their actions that person
gets psychiatric help and is like put maybe put in a hold it's
given psychiatric help medicated
that happens but no instead of actually we should just we should
just like get rid of d process and these people okay do you think
that benefits you like you think getting ready due process is
going to benefit you in the long run and people around you or
do you think that's going to be used against
Yeah, that's that some somehow it's shocking how often you can
come to like the correct opinion or know something silly if you
just think of like it's so easy. How would I feel if this was
applied to me? How would I feel if this was applied to somebody
I care about? It's like oh all of the things I'm arguing for
are total dog [__] They're like they don't make any
sense. They would be disastrous if if like uh somebody who didn't
hold my ideological beliefs could have forced them on me or could
use them on me. >> Yep. And nobody ever uh nobody ever
seems to care or want to believe it or want to think about it.
Like the easiest thought exercise that you can go through. Oh
boy. All right. Well,
guys, I think that's uh it's probably it for the stream. Well,
you know what? It's actually not it for the stream. Hold on.
I'm going to watch a little bit more of this uh panel. I want
to get through at least a little bit more of this panel. Maybe
another 30 minutes of it. Any uh highlights from this? Cuz I
know it goes quite long.
>> you watch any of it or sorry, I know you watch some
of it. a little bit.
>> Uh, are there any highlights? Um, probably the callins
you skip towards the end. Probably better than the main panel
to be honest. >> Oh, really? Who calls in? >> Soy
pill calls in and he's just like it's like watching a you know
die hard true believer DJ just begging and pleading like no surely
you're not saying that we should just go out and kill the public.
Surely Desi you're not saying that. It's very funny.
>> It's funny. Does he respond the same way he did to uh
the this guy the lawyer guy? Cuz I love that his response is
like don't fed post right now. Right. And I I feel like that's
another thing he got like super mad at Vosch about was Vosch
being like don't fed post when he was somebody's asking about
if he's calling for violence. I'm positive that that happened.
>> yeah, this guy is this guy's been mad gay. This guy's
been mad gay. Like say stand on it or don't say it. And if you're
going to say it, you should be ready to do it. >> Yep.
He certainly like he's equipped. What is he being equipped for?
>> All right.
>> Where is the DG militia? I am calling upon Steven and
Kenneth Desty another second to form >> the problem with
DJ owning guns. Same issue with uh Ah, never mind. Never mind.
Never mind. Never mind. Never mind. Never mind. >> They're
all trans. Is that the problem with it? They're all trans. >> Dude,
what the Why do none of my kick bands work anymore? All these
people I ban don't say banned. [__] going on? Got
to ban people. They don't say banned. Are kickbands just not
working? What's going on? >> Why'd you ban Joac? >> He
just spams. >> I told him he couldn't call you N stalk
anymore. Like [__] stalk. So he started. >> He
just like doesn't he doesn't like me and he spams Chad. So I
I That's fine. You don't have to watch. >> The other day
came into my chat and said Joe just you said this exactly. >> Yeah.
Wait, wait, wait. Are you going to read the exact screenshot
you sent me that I didn't respond to when you sent it to me on
my stream? Is that what you want to do right now? That's what
you want to do? >> Let me read this out. Let me read this
out. Let me read this out real quick. He
>> "Anyway, that's it for the stream." No, it's not >> hard
right now because they are accelerationist on the >> I'll
let him I'll let him read card right now and it seems to be your
play
>> like he's like you should pull this up and then if I
don't pull it up he'll like come on and start talking about it.
It's like bro no means
>> stop having a DG concept of consent. Okay, what is happening?
>> Had with an Asian female one hour ago. Can you either
say the same about Jeetalk? I didn't think so. Je. That's what
this guy said. >> This guy has a DJ's concept of consent.
It's weird right now. >> Where is it? I want to see it.
>> Where's what? >> What's talking about? >> Oh,
he's talking about this screenshot.
>> Hold on. Did you delete this in DMs? You delete this
message, too. >> Oh, it's in DMs. Oh, it's in DMs. >> Oh,
here it is. Yeah, here it is. >> What? What's a Jade stock?
>> Uh, it's me. If I was obsessed with Indian people instead
of uh
>> instead of instead of other people. No, you're Indian.
He's calling you Indian. >> Wait, so then the one is just
I'm as >> Yeah, but he never said he never called you Jew.
Sorry. He was you he said [__] stalk and he he would
say like [__] stalk is a subhuman. [__]
[__] stalk should be >> Yeah, I know that guy's
like schizophrenic. I I understand. I understand fully. It's
like the most offensive thing. It's not. It's actually fine.
He's just He's just schizophrenic. Anybody who's schizophrenic
and spams my chat I just remove. >> Oh man, that's a funny
guy. That's a funny chatter.
>> Might be you're looking for. >> Okay. He also
dude, have you heard his name for not soite?
>> Let me type it to you. This is what people mean when
they type Nsk. Okay. >> Okay. All right. Yeah, I can see
why this guy fits in. I can see why this guy fits in in your
community. Yeah, I get it. I get it.
Uh-huh. Okay. Is that NSNK? All right. >> Why are you guys
like this? >> I don't know why they're like that. It's
very weird.
I don't know why they're like that.
>> That's so good, man. >> Okay. Is jealous he doesn't
have his own Joe. I do. I just We have to keep them wrapped in
chains. Okay. We don't We don't like these people getting out.
They They can't break containment. Okay. All right. What am I
looking for? See the the Collins are good. >> Yeah. What's
funny? There he is. Little little hat. I see him with his goofy
little hat. Oh, he calls in way earlier than that. All right.
>> Do it. If you ask me a year ago, I'd say [__]
Oh, no. >> Oh, wait, wait, wait. He's Yeah, he calls in.
Camera's not on. GG. >> Hopefully, sir. And we're going
to go quickly through these, by the way. >> Yeah. Look,
Chris was right here. Like, come on. >> Is there Chris?
I raid crisp. Do you raid Do you raid Joe? I raid Crisp all the
time. >> Doesn't stream.
>> Got to fix that. Gotta fix that. Gotta fix that. >> We
will have to bring him on after. Um Okay. Well, in that case,
>> no, I'm here. Uh is my camera not turning on? >> It's
not. Give us what you got, though. >> Okay. Okay. Um Destiny,
I I don't I I I apologize. You had to talk to people who don't
believe in January 6 cuz I think I I can just go ahead and concede.
We have the exact same views of everything on the right wing.
Uh that's not what I wanted to talk about. I This idea of like
not deescalating is very confusing to me cuz I'm I don't know
what you're trying to advocate for. like uh when people on the
right wing right now are calling for like more violence, we're
going to war. Like meeting them where they are in terms of playing
dirty and saying let's gerrymander uh you know uh California
to make sure they can't steal seats makes perfect sense to me.
Let's talk let's make jokes. Let's like absolutely not like go
high because they went low. What do you like where does this
lead when we're meeting them when they're talking about this
violent rhetoric? Like what do you actually say? I would say
very simply tit for tat. The other side can't feel like they
can >> Oh, there it is. There it is, guys. We called it,
didn't we? This is just going to say tit for tat because he has
no brain in his skull. Okay, he's he read a Wikipedia page on
game theory. It said tit for tat game theory. Oh my god, there
it is. >> Um everything. I understand the secrecy of universe
now. They say you win
>> Incredible stuff. >> And operate violently with
impunity. Number one, my question to you, you responded one and
two. My question for you. Number two, when the South wanted to
secede, should we have allowed them to do that? >> No,
absolutely not. and and going to war was an okay way to stop
that, >> right? Uh but are we saying that what the right
is doing right now is akin to
>> It's it's approaching that. Yeah. When Donald Trump
talks about sending the military to states to to take over law
enforcement things from them when Gavin Newsome is making a speech
inside and the federal officers are ordered to be stationed outside
is it's not like a >> are either so one of those I know
is he's sending uh what
one is the army going into cities not for immigration to just
uphold the law. I don't even know what this is. And then the
Gavin Newsome thing, I have no idea. Usually when Destiny starts
listing things, they're not very powerful. So, I would have to
look into both of those. >> I don't know. I I feel like,
you know, Destiny's these things don't quite
get Destiny's I don't think they fully support his point, but
I also think they are things that should concern you about a
level of hostility from the government and should put you on
edge. But are they I don't know that they're h I don't think
they're like quite equipped to the what do you call or sorry
not not equipped they're not like um on the same thing. I think
there's like this fascist element of the government that Charlie
Kirk Charlie Kirk was two things right he was this he was a plugged
into the government in a way that people kind of downplay right
now and he was like an influencer and I think he was shot almost
entirely as an influencer. I wouldn't be shocked if the guy who
shot him had very little tangible understanding of how connected
he was to the White House and like to the decision of the government.
>> He probably just hated him because he was on TikTok
all the time. And >> that's what I think. Yeah, exactly.
>> So like I think there's like two different things happening.
One is you should be scared of like the government and it's overreach,
but I don't know if that's happening downh
it's it's happening down partisan lines, but there's like something
different. There's like some overlapping thing happening there.
That's um
>> No, I think you should be I think if I think the National
Guard and uh you should like that is like legit like
>> that that is like signaling that you're prepping for
like civil war basically that that is the signaling that's happening
there when you're like going into California with National Guard.
That that is the signaling. >> So um >> what is the
National Guard going to California for? like what is the what
is the actual >> it's well it's to up I think the reason
they were deployed in basically all the states was to uphold
the law and stop crime was basically the the excuse right and
but the governors or whatever weren't actually consenting to
it happening and that a key part
>> to defend federal property was his reasoning how much
is he sending to each
due to protest on ICE I don't know they deployed all the federal
law enforcement agencies okay well maybe we'll have to look into
this tomorrow. Look into this like after uh stream today. Yeah,
I guess. Hold on. And then the second one was something with
Gavin Newsome. Yeah, >> Yeah, something about Gavin Newsome's
>> They had um they had like a they had some dudes, I think
it was FBI dudes on like an APC, like a military APC, and they're
driving all over the grass on the Utah campus for the Charlie
Kirk thing. And it's like like the next day or like two days
later. It's like, bro, are you just there for a photo op? Why
are you up their grass? It's like, dude, the laring from police
officers is so out of control. It's so out of control and crazy.
Like, they there's literally nobody's around. They're just driving
around on this grass. They literally drive over the grass instead
of driving around from parking lot to parking lot. They just
don't want to take the street. They just drive over the grass
and it's like a bunch of guys hanging off the back of this APC.
It's so stupid. Anyway, direct path towards what that looks like,
right? So, if you're talking about like abusing power and authority
to maybe like get some things done in certain ways, like I'm
not opposed to >> No, hold on. I'm not talking about abusing
power and authority, I'm talking about Donald Trump, the commander-in-chief
of our armed forces, the president of the United States, stealing
the National Guard from governors in states and then deploying
them against those states in order to do
>> so for that exact for that exact thing, right? Like
how do you match people there? Like what is the match? What is
like cuz if you're talking about escalate right we we can quote
the the off to the the not >> I just I don't know we'll
see if they're ready to step up to the plate I disavow obviously
a disgusting thing that's happening seems like he's at least
he's you know targeted at least he's targeted right he's you
made it very clear >> exactly be clear with what you mean
be clear with what you this is the problem you know there's it's
never a good idea for some
uh political you know thinker as Destiny sees himself to go out
there and They just do violence. You know, you got to direct
it. So, I'm glad Destiny has finally told these years if you
want to effectively save America. Okay. Probably can't say the
full thing, but that's what Destiny's saying. >> That's
what he's saying. I disavow that. I don't think that's a good
idea. >> He's saying he's Taylor Ren's pill. He's saying
8647. >> To be fair, Taylor Ren said actually explicitly
don't do that at the end of her video. Like, I don't think you
should do that. But Destiny is not Listen, Destiny will take
back his calls for Donald Trump's head. All right. Once Donald
Trump disavows the violence, that's that's the bargain he's made
with Donald Trump. Make sure Donald Trump understands that, guys.
Okay? Donald Trump needs to know these years are coming for him
unless he stops. >> The deal of the deal. I'm going to
stop uh breaking federal law. Uh if you give me a concession,
>> stop breaking federal law. No, it's federal law for
federal law. Hey, Donald Trump, you're not respecting the Constitution
of my country. Okay? Once you respect the Constitution of my
country, I'll respect federal law. I won't I'll stop calling
for your head. We'll call down the DGRs. They'll tell him stand
back and stand by voted part of the second amendment with the
state militias. I all I'm saying is that you cannot lay down
and die, right? It has to be a tip for >> I agree obviously,
but the difference between like, oh, let's not deescalate as
in
Donald Trump to lower. >> So the tit for tat here is that
you won't disavow the violence. You want the violence amped up
for them for Donald Trump overreaching with his executive authority
doesn't seem like it's a tit for tat. They're like totally like
not remotely comparable >> at the temperature
as well. That was like uh for any right-wingers looking to retaliate,
just let you know, everyone on the left takes all their all their
cues from this guy Steven Kenneth Destiny.
>> I saw that. I didn't pull that up on stream for obvious
reasons, but I did see it.
>> Say, "Hey, chill." >> Right. But you you and I
both know he's never going to do that. So, what are you actually
advocating for the left? for everyone on the left to say all
say that the temperature needs to go down when Donald Trump does.
>> What's the point if you know Donald Trump's not going
to do that? Like what are you actually saying when you say meet
them where they are? This is the prisoners dilemma. We have to
do exactly what they're doing. What are we doing? Like like if
like when I say that I say okay yeah absolutely if Gavin Newsome
is going to be like carving up
in Prisoners Dilemma what's the worst outcome for you?
>> Uh that you go to jail for like a life because you didn't
agree for the 5 years that you would both get right. >> Yeah.
Prisoner's dilemma. Worst outcome is not the civil war part.
It's not where both of you betray each other. The worst outcome
in in the prisoner's dilemma is when they defect and you cooperate.
Right. >> Right. Again, so this is why I'm trying to get
this out of you is like what do you actually advocate?
>> That's assuming you're symmetric partners. That's assuming
you have symmetric actions you could take. That's the whole point
of the prisoners dilemma. This guy is intentionally or possibly
not intentionally. He seems to have lost any intellect he previously
had. So possibly he's just actually misunderstanding the prisoner's
dilemma. This is when you have symmetric actions. Guess what?
Government ain't got symmetric actions with you, bro. If the
Trump administration has proven anything, it's that the Trump
administration can do whatever the [__] they want.
I don't I don't think you should lay down, but oh my goodness.
Trying to use the prisoners dilemma as like a reason to escalate
to decentralized violence when the government's like overreaching.
I don't know, man. And like also, you're not disavowing an attack
on Charlie Kirk.
It's just >> advocating for to meet something on the right.
Like if Matt Walsh is saying, "Let's commit violence. Let's crack
down. Let's do some insane." Are you saying the left should also
be saying >> I mean, I don't know. It seems like everybody's
getting violent now. So, the left has to say anything like that.
Um,
I'm just saying I would say that's what I'm saying. So, that's
not meeting them where they are. >> You should say what
the You should say what Elizabeth Warren is saying, which is
I'm not going to say about turning down the temperature until
Donald Trump says [__] about turning down the temperature.
That's it. >> Okay. But to me that's a meaningless statement
because you're not saying meaningless statement >> because
no prescriptively like what do you actually because when I hear
this when I hear you saying this oh it's the prisoners dilemma
and I'm looking at how bad the right wing is right now. It's
like oh are you saying we should take up arms and prepare for
the actual civil war right now which is arms to defend yourself.
I think you should to do that for sure. >> But what are
you actually advocating for in terms of meeting some of these
crazy like Laura Loomer Valentina Gomez people on the right wing?
Like I don't I just think dude I just have to keep thinking in
my head of like just how disgusting this is that he's like copied
Vos's entire bit. Okay.
Like have some shame, dude. If you're going to copy the dude's
whole flow, like can we just can we get like an homage to Vosch
somewhere in like the background or something? Can we get like
a picture of your your spiritual leader? You know how North Koreans
have the pictures of like Kim Jong-un on their on their wall?
Can we get that like a picture of Vosch for destiny so he knows
who his supreme leader is? I need that. I need something like
I need an acknowledgement. >> I think that we should be
saying like, "Yep, we should start executing these people." Yeah,
we should start rounding them up. And like I get the education
camps like this seems like a total uh deviation from what I would
advocate for, which is we're not going to back down. We are not
going to stop fighting, but that doesn't mean we necessarily
have to match every single thing. >> Something in this
I think it's in this colon is like you remember Vos specifically
was also talking about like trans people. He was talking about
stuff about defending themselves, right? >> Wait, he says
that? >> Yeah. Destiny basically says that in this. Yeah.
>> Basically hops hits the trans people
>> Oh well, so he actually knows who he's copying from.
Okay, fair enough. >> He's like fullblown
skinwalker now
doing toning down the rhetoric is one thing. Like hey yeah, let's
not cause for violence. That doesn't mean you have to All right.
Yeah, like step on my back and do whatever you want. Like that's
I'm trying to get you to clarify what you're actually prescriptively
asking the leftwing to do. cuz if it's already what they're doing,
Gavin Newsome, Elizabeth Warren, that does not seem that crazy.
But that's not what is coming out of your mouth. That's not how
a lot of people are reading it.
>> Just an FYI, my Reddit account was banned from LSF for
trying to post the pin tweet. I think Gregor Sama, if I had to
guess, stale would do that sweeping. And then he would say, "Actually,
you can't really post that on here cuz they're going to blame
LSF and they're going to ban the subreddit." So, we can't post
stuff like that on here. Would be something like, "Okay, that
that's basically bees excuse." So cool. Read it however you want
then. If you don't like how you're reading it for me, then tell
the right to chill out. >> Honestly, I see LSF as an equivalent
evil to MAGA, frankly.
>> Well, read it how >> not a but LSF directly.
>> Yeah. O is part of that.
>> Whatever you want then. If you don't like how you're
reading it for me, then tell the right to chill it out. >> I
mean, I don't want to have to be the silencer on the Destiny
filter saying, "Hey, he doesn't mean be violent, guys. He just
means what the left's already doing." Which is, you know, if
that is what you mean, cool. But like mean anything. You can
direct them to any video. I'll say the exact same thing. What
should the left do? The left should say Donald Trump needs to
turn it down. And until he does, it don't say anything about
any violence or whatever. Whatever is happening is happening.
I'm not telling people to take up arms and go kill him. I'm just
saying whatever happens is happening. And he's trying to be slick.
Okay. >> He's such a good thing about what happens is happening.
Whatever happens. What do you mean by that, bro? >> I mean,
you call him a But the good thing about Destiny is he does not
have the self-control to ever maintain a position like this,
right? If if people are going to accuse him of being a [__]
he will always just say the thing like he can be goated into
it at all times. No, Koser, he already explicitly said he wants
like violence. He already explicitly said, "I want these people
scared. I'm happy they're scared. Temperature can go down when
Donald Trump turns it down." He said that >> What guy?
>> Yeah. Well, that's the that's the state of our country
right now is what Donald Trump wants it to be, right? So, you're
going to be violent. Would >> this be a prescription? Would
this be a >> So, the housekeeping thing since your camera
just isn't working. So, >> um, my theory there is, yeah,
one of one of two things. Either he's either he handed over some
hard drives that have some [__] and he's looking
at like hard time and so he just wants to go out before that
happens or uh, he is possibly invited to like Eerite's birthday
and just wants to have an excuse to sit inside and not go. >> It's
like one of the two. I'm not sure >> You're going to have
to give us your last thing and then we're going to cycle out.
Okay. >> You're going to cycle me out in the middle of
my my my roll. >> Are you in the middle of your role? >> I'm
in the middle of my roll. You can't see me. >> Finish the
clip. >> No, no clip needed. >> You shouldn't even
be here. >> The end position is no violence. Just demand
mutual condemnation. No, the the end position is exactly what
he said. I want you scared. I want you worried about violence.
I won't disavow the violence. And that threat of violence, that
looming threat of possible violence that you're concerned won't
will remain as long as we don't say anything about it. That's
what I want to pressure you into doing the right thing. You are
just threatening them. Kton, that's an explicit threat. It's
an obvious and explicit threat. >> It's just like so obvious
what he's saying. Like I I He literally he's already argued.
He argued two piece go up to the line of saying Donald Trump
should be shot after the assassination attempt. He refused to
actually explicitly state say the words, "Yes, Donald Trump should
be assassinated,
but he ended it saying, I'm not going to fed post right now.
You're fed post right now." Whatever. He walked right up to the
line and refused to say it. He's doing the same thing here. He's
walking right up to the line of saying there should be, you know,
terrorist attacks on a speeches and you should be aggra influencers.
You should be Donald Trump and just not saying it. He's right
up to line and just won't do it. >> Wait, didn't he do
this with uh harassing like us as well?
Wasn't he like you guys are just aren't you aren't taking this
far enough or something? I he was going over some [__]
on stream and that's like some expression he gave was like you
I I thought you guys would like take this more seriously and
like do something about this but I guess I have to do it and
then he like went through some doc on stream or or something
along these lines. I can't remember it fully now.
it's I sorry it's just like um yeah he's uh he's just like constantly
trying to signal out to people the things he wants to happen.
He's like,
it's weird how much he's all the things he said that like Bosch
was. It's very bizarre to me. Like, do you think that haunts
him at all? I guess not. Depending on if he quotes Vos here over
the trans defense >> he doesn't quote him, but he he does,
you know, he mentions the trans people. You have to see the quote.
He says basically saying like, um, we're all like white people
here, so matter to any of us, but if you're like trans or you're
like black. >> Oh, I see. You have nothing valuable to
add to this conversation. So, doesn't Yeah. You you don't even
believe in January 6, dude. Just whatever. Anyway, Jesse, so
are you advocating for it when someone on the left is to like
let's say, okay, let's say this Charlie Kirk thing comes out.
Turns out this guy was a hardcore lefty. He was like, "Yep, everyone,
I was totally like invigorated by this, this, and this, and all
these leftwing points, and this was the defend the trans community."
You're saying we should not denounce that. All the people that
you used and showed look how much better the left wing is doing.
Uh, you know, President Obama, Joe Biden, all these people are
denouncing this. Even George W. Bush, I think, did it. Donald
Trump. I'm not trying to say we have to hold ourselves to the
Donald Trump standard, but are you saying, "Oh, no, we shouldn't
denounce that." >> You ceue up the denouncement and you
say, "I'm ready to denounce it. Let me hear Donald Trump denounce
violence on his side first." >> What? What does that do?
>> It makes the other side calm their [__]
down. What do you mean what does it do? >> No, it doesn't.
You
>> If Donald Trump uses this is to label the Democratic
party a terrorist organization, have it higher ups arrested and
all that. What is your prescription? Um, I think the prescription
would be you get guns and you start pressuring any military family
members, you have to do the right thing. Military at that point
has to do its duty. That's what that's what I hope for, right?
Um, is that your military is like led by people who realize that
your democracy is important and if somebody's actually directly
threatening it in that exact way >> if they sponsor the
Constitution seriously. Imagine. >> Yeah. That's like that's
like the the prayer that you have at that point. That's not Civil
War. I think I think that will happen. I think that's what's
happened in the past is the uh I think your military leadership
has
>> Well, I think your military has explicitly ignored
um like your president like Donald Trump telling them to do things
that like they shouldn't be doing. I think they do realize that
they have to I don't know ignore them in some cases. Need to
get you to fed post yourself. I'm not fed posting. I said I hope
the military does their duty. I'm not I'm not advocating citizens
do it. I think the military has the right to do that basically.
I think that's kind of understood. Um, what am I looking for
here? Notice Destiny gets extremely unhinged when he feels like
the right is winning. 2022 midterms. He freaked out. Trump assassination.
Now this is extremely emotionally compromised. Yeah, true. All
right, we continue. >> You and I both agree. Donald Trump
is not going to back down. >> Stop. If it doesn't, then
it wouldn't do anything if we do it either. So then [__]
it. Easy. >> It does. Because the problem that you're facing
here that's
why you're trying to get another sentime. That's all I'm going
to say because you're not because it doesn't because it doesn't
seem like you're actually advocating for anything right now.
What you're saying is advocating for it. I'm advocating for you
to pressure the right to tell their side to stop being >> How
are you going to pressure them? You're he's he's he's telling
you exactly what he wants you to do, right? He the pressure is
very obvious. It's it's those it's that video of Charlie Kirk
bleeding out. Okay, >> that's the pressure. >> Why
are you advocating for that when you and I both know that they're
not going to do it? >> I think they will eventually. >> Wait,
are we going to war? >> No, dude. Donald Trump is never
going to back down. >> They either do it or we end up I
guess all each other. That's it. I mean, what do you mean? No,
because the the difference is I like Wick I believe that there's
tons of offramps like for example Donald Trump dies of a stroke.
I think they're just going to lose a ton of momentum. If uh you
know uh you know they say oh violence violence violence that's
like not a good argument. What if Donald Trump strokes out and
they just stop doing what they're doing?
That's like though maybe the worst argument you could offer in
return to that isn't it? >> What if it's just like divine
intervention? What if we just like you know totally out of nowhere
just like totally saved? >> How about that? Wouldn't that
be awesome? I think that's a that's like a horrible like okay
I totally think nonviolence is the is the way but um
maybe Donald Trump will have a stroke and then everything will
be okay maybe >> so guy from what I've seen him is can
be dumb as rocks I'm not going to lie >> maybe the earth
will open up and swallow Donald Trump
maybe like this is very similar to what they were doing post
Trump assassination and yet post that like absolutely nothing
escalated to a degree that I think anyone is expecting when people
are crying out civil war because it's, you know, they're [__]
everyone forgets and this stuff like goes to the wayside. Like
if you truly truly believe like if like I don't believe this
that we are in an existential moment in such that we cannot solve
this electorally then yeah I would tell people yeah I don't even
need to deescalate. You should go get arms and we should go fight
in the streets but we're not even close to that yet. Like that
yet have they? If they say that then maybe I'll start saying
that. Just say what they say. >> Okay. So right and if
there's what no can continue and if they're saying things such
as hey let us >> uh I think something that people just
fail to understand completely I made this point earlier but I
I want to see how you think about it. Um the reason Donald Trump's
rhetoric works is because he's got like the dumbest mouth breathing
like slobbering section of society who operates as his primary
base. Um they do not want to vote for Democrats. They do not
like Democrats. You cannot get them. And so when you do this,
like you are opting to to signal towards by being the party that
believes in science and all of this. You're opting to signal
towards a smarter class of voter. And I don't know, it's possible
that America just doesn't have enough intelligent people. There's
just too many mouth breathers that you can't win by not being
populist. But like he's arguing for like populist rhetoric for
a party that is not doing a populist approach. And it seems totally
disconnected. I don't know if he realizes that. I don't know
if most people realize that. Yeah. >> Wait, who who's arguing
for that? >> Destiny. like he's he's trying to take Donald
Trump's approach to like the political violence thing, but he
doesn't have the v voter base for the Democrats that appreciate
that, that want that. >> I agree on that,
but I think I disagree broadly. I think
>> a lot of people do want just populist rhetoric and people
being super
>> Wait, they do want popular. >> No, I mean I mean
intelligent people want that as well.
Um, >> at this point, I think it's just the way social
media is change politics. >> Uh, I don't I don't know if
intelligent people want that in the same way. I don't know if
they want the things that go along with that, right? Cuz you've
already got the intelligent people. So, you don't you're not
going to lose intelligent people by not doing populist rhetoric
in my opinion. >> Well, okay. Well, let's say if you're
taking intelligence mean like, you know, agrees with me. I I
feel like there's a lot of intelligent not engaged people that
just like, you know, their exposure to politics is Tik Tok after
work.
Um >> Sure, sure. And and the way they get the way you
win that is by
saying Trump's >> Yeah. Um Yeah. Sure. Sure. Sure. But
that's that's the other thing of um that's the other thing of
populist rhetoric is when people say, "Hey, Desi, will you disavow
the violence?" He said, "We're not." You basically don't allow
yourself to go into those conversations. You're you're just attacking.
Right. So he keeps commenting on what his position is and he
lets people ask him what his position is because he doesn't want
to run from the questions.
>> You you just deflect an attack, right? You just say
like, "Yeah, sure, violence is bad, but that's the handle it,
>> But he's letting himself be pinned down in a way that
Trump won't, right? >> Yeah. Sure. >> And that's
that's like a huge problem, too, is you're like you're giving
a position that like I can identify and a ton of people can identify
that he's just calling for violence directly. People can identify
that with Trump, but it's not quite the same. Like Trump's just
going to constantly rail on radical Democrats. He'll just he'll
basically he sounds like an old man that can't hear, right? He's
just like making his points the whole time. I think that's like
a core requirement >> clip. The ballroom clip. Oh my god.
>> How are you doing today? How you holding up today? Uh
terrific. We're finishing construction on the ballroom. Yeah,
he's awesome, man.
>> So based. >> Yeah, exactly.
I
I think I think people I don't understand that that's like a
key part of like Donald Trump. He does look quite bad in situations
where he kind of gets like held down to like on questions. He
does look quite bad. Um but he just doesn't let people do that.
Um Koser, you can say that, but people do take him seriously.
No, the right does take him seriously. They absolutely take him
seriously. Like a huge chunk of people take him seriously. Yeah,
I understand Kosa feels like, you know, all the other right-wing
voters must be as enlightened as the graers that he talks to
who realize that the complex political incentives and whatever
the but no, most like Trump voters are like actual trodites who
think, "Oh, he's like a really good businessman. That means he's
really good at running the country."
That's like what they actually think. That's like 90% of them.
>> Dude, I I'm not going to lie. Can't I can't just keep
glazing Hassan. If you wanted a populist left movement, put Hassan
up there. Okay. Hassan will
I'm I'm not I'm not [__] joking. >> That's
the black pill these people tough pill to swallow. >> You
need to eventually.
>> You want You want somebody who can criticize Trump?
Get somebody.
This is Every populace understands this. Why do you think Trump
only hires like attractive women to run all of his [__]
He he tries to hire attractive women even like he he like tried
to find the most attractive lawyer he could to be like his uh
his attorney general is he understands the the optics of that.
Okay.
People don't want to swallow that pill. That's a that's a rough
one. I don't want to I don't want to It just is the way it is.
Okay. >> Take take the black pill. Except everything everything
is looks maxing.
It's all looks maxing all the way down. >> It is.
It makes us correct on everything. Okay. We hate to admit it.
It's rough. Crack down. Let's throw these people in camps. Let's
like take guns away from trans people. It's like, okay, are we
going to start advocating for that? Or are we just saying, hey,
I like are we are we going to say, I'm not doing stochastic terrorism,
but I'm not going to denounce people that that do a terrorism
until you do it. Like, what is this accomplishing if one, you
and I both acknowledge this is not going to change their minds?
And two, in your prisoners dilemma, guys, I love I love how that
worked for Israel and Palestine. Okay, we're not going to stop
until they stop. That turned out really well. That's amazing
stuff. You've got people on the right who are calling for violence
and then people on the left who are meeting them there. But then
all these people in the middle who are not part of this prisoners
dilemma who are like the 66% of people I guess according to pre-ress
research who says politics is way too volatile right now and
are screaming and and begging for a solution. And now an entire
side of people are like actually no there's nothing for you to
look out for. Everyone is extreme. We're all calling for violence.
We will refuse to denounce it. Like then the democracy is dead.
If that's how people are then the experiment has failed. People
shouldn't be allowed to vote freely. And then we go to the next
form of whatever government is either the socialists are happy
we move to that or we do some type of monarchy or >> you
know we're nowhere close to that. You know we're nowhere close
to that. >> Keep saying that. People keep saying that but
the situation is getting more and more >> every time I
hear like a lib say this like automocracy is over. It's like
you it's like they're just rediscovering for the first time like
uh the fact that most people are actually not that smart. you
know that mo most voters, most people and stuff just kind of
dumb and it's hard to get through to them and you kind kind of
need to play like games to win them over that aren't about the
actual issues. It's like yeah like no like I feel like everyone
most people like figure this out as like >> the bread and
circuses
>> like a 15year-old or something. >> Sure. They
figured it out 2,000 years ago. It's not that hard to remain,
you know, understood now. Hey, it turns out most people actually
don't care about the most people like with tangible policy aren't
even going to like have the issues they have now to care about
when that policy gets passed. You run a policy, it's like right
like you you would even run on a policy, pass it, and then by
the time like the person who voted for it because they had that
need like they're it's going to be 10 years later before that
really starts coming around with almost everything. And unless
it's like a tax credit and like they're going to be moved past
having that issue. I don't know.
Socialists are happy. We move to that or we do some type of monarchy
or >> you know we're nowhere close to that. You know we're
nowhere close to that. >> You keep saying that. People
keep saying that but the situation is getting more and more insane.
No. Have you met me? >> No. It is absolutely
video two days ago. It's crazy. >> I I acknowledge that
you and I are not going to disagree on a single thing about how
crazy the rightwing. >> It's kind of it's a little crazy
to me that it's like Charlie Kirk just got shot. Things are crazy
right now. And it's like it's it almost sounds like he's on the
other side of that, right? Like he's he's like on the Charlie
Kirk >> He's saying, "Let's get crazier." He's saying,
"No, we need to make this crazier. This needs to get worse."
>> Thing is, what I'm asking you is like what do you if
if you think the only way to like combat this right now is to
pressure them into like imagine like shaming the right wing into
like toning down violence when we both know that's not going
to happen. And and maybe it could happen if left-wingers do enough
violence and we say, "Well, we'll tone it down when you do."
Like what what is this? Where does this get us? What is going
to happen after this? Then eventually people either tone it down
or we go to full-on conflict. I guess and that seems like but
why are these the two only options? >> Where does Okay,
where does your situation get us if we constantly disavow and
the right just keeps amping it up? >> Uh if they get more
violent and they lose the election then it doesn't nearly matter
nearly as much if we have the >> Wait, they win the election
cuz what do people always say? I bet you even said it. The left
is feckless. The left doesn't do anything. The left is weak.
Let's say that they keep amping it up and and the left doesn't
respond. Let's say that Donald Trump, which he's kind of geared
up to do. I don't know if he'll actually do it. If you would
ask me a year ago, I'd say no. Now I'm not sure. Let's say Donald
Trump doesn't find a way to with the election uh next year, right?
Unless they find a way to keep whatever majority they need. They
really don't need all with Congress because it's not like Trump
listens to Congress anyway. And they and the everything keeps
ramping up on the right. What is what is the outcome
>> Thank God. >> Like obviously if we get to the
point where it's like, oh, the rightwing is escalating. They're
seizing power. Trump >> One second. I just clicked on a
still from Pisco stream. Uh I I have to open this up and see
what he's doing.
>> Hold on. Let me Let me pull this up for you guys. He's
debating DJ Cheers, isn't >> Uh, he's debating kidn. But,
um, this is this is the drawing he has going on screen right
now. Kid virtue signaling equals signaling what is good. Oh,
this is this says I love puppies down here and it's like it's
got a picture of a
Sorry. It's just it made me laugh when I pulled it up for a quick
second and I was just like, oh, I have to see what's actually
going on here. Trump runs for a third term. He turns off the
elections
Okay, so I'm not saying that we're not on the list. haven't gone
far enough yet, right? We have the same position. You just haven't
got far enough yet. So, what's the line for you? >> Yes.
Well, the line for me is not where we are now where I think there's
obviously a way that we can electorally win both the midterms
and the next
>> I hate when we do. You say you're not there yet, so
what's the line for you? And he says, "Well, it's not where we
are now." Yeah. No, that's in the premise of the question, you
[__] >> Sure. Sure. Yeah. I think the line
has to be the democratic process um being [__] with
in the same way that January 6th was and knowing that like at
that point it's it's like over. You would love it for it to be
January 6, but clearly that wasn't enough to galvanize people.
You hope the next time, like with you constantly sowing about
it, people see it.
>> I don't know.
>> The line is where it's like there is no electoral outcome
where this ever matters, so we need to fight back and be violent
about it. But we're just not in that moment right now. >> Okay.
So if in 2026
if they start with the with the vote, so for instance, they have
done this a little bit like when Congress wrote a letter to Texas
saying, "Hey, we need you to wipe off five of your districts."
If other Texas if other states start falling in line with that
of white >> if I believe if I believe the courts are so
[__] that if he like does an executive order ban
mail and votes shuts down the polling stations and it's like
there is literally no path >> can't save you my dude he
tried to right away naturalize birth with an executive order
why the courts can't save you >> literally can because
we were like have TRO's on certain like electoral uh executive
orders that he's doing right now. Like don't get me wrong, I'm
not saying this is not a dire situation. >> My dude, the
courts just got rid of the injunction. What are you talking about?
The courts are >> talking about the idea that if you think
that there's no pressure to fighting back against what Trump's
doing and anything in the system right now, which is is very
weird coming from you because like I I don't think that you believe
in this like oh the establishment is completely feckless and
they'll never be able to get anything done. There's nothing we
can do about it. Like >> like surely Destiny, surely you're
not telling me to go out Trump. Surely that's not what you're
telling me to do. Like that's literally what's happening >> I
mean all I'm hearing is surely you're not you're not saying the
things Vosch said. Surely you're not walking me right up to that
line. And surely you're not telling me there's no hope, there's
no possible democratic solution, and that I have to arm myself.
I have to be prepared. There's no way, right? That's all I hear.
He desperately doesn't want to be led to believe that Vosch is
is correct about everything >> Trump's doing in anything
in the system right now, which is is very weird coming from you
because like I I don't think that you believe in this like, oh,
the establishment is completely feckless and they'll never be
able to get >> Is that you lighting the cigarette or is
that somebody on here? >> I cigarette guy. >> Anything
done? There's nothing we can do about it. seems so black and
doomer like yeah if we're there absolutely I'm going to like
you know start forming my little like military militia but we're
nowhere close to the I mean no okay don't get me wrong when I
say we're nowhere close
we're on the precipice of a lot of things this is why I'm blackpilled
Donald Trump this morning on Fox and friends okay was asked what
should we do or what you know what people say that they're worried
or whatever what do you think about like bringing the country
back together and Donald Trump says I don't care about bringing
the country back together okay you you hear me say that right
>> Jenz and tally has Donald Trump done enough yet for
you to have voted for Kamla instead No, that's exactly that's
the point, right? So, yeah, it's [__]
>> I would agree with you 100% if Jen Z was every single
voter in the middle in the independent. Uh, Jenzia, we can both
acknowledge as a talally have also called this for the same thing.
Unless you disavow and say you wouldn't vote for Trump anymore.
I think there are so many people like, let's put it this way,
Destiny, I followed all of your laws. I followed all of the laws
of the DGer. Destiny, surely you can, Destiny, please. These
people are they don't understand the way of the DGR, but I do.
I'm I'm an acolyte. My parents don't know who the [__]
Charlie. I do truly believe Tally is like genuinely subhuman.
This is like someone that I can't express my feelings about.
I genuinely can't. >> I just I just uh
allow me to express my true feelings about Taliban. >> I
just can't imagine like could you imagine if not so Erdite went
on a panel was like yeah I'm voting for Trump um because he wants
more favorable trade deals with Canada. Could you imagine if
she did that? Like that would be like, "Yeah, cut this person's
cut the head of their painting brush off." Okay. And send them
back to the country they came from, I think, would be the appropriate
response, right? Like voting for
>> I'm saying voting for a candidate based on how they
how like your other another country is is dealt with. Okay, that's
I I lose it. I lose it completely. >> Well, it's not even
about that. She refused to say it's about that. Oh, I could have
sworn she said it was about Israel in the [__] I
saw. >> No, no, no, no, no. She will say it's not about
Israel. It's about the fact
Democrats have allowed themselves become infested with far-left
anti-semitic
radical, anti-ionist, whatever. It's like about Hassan. >> she
didn't vote. She voted Trump because of Hassan. She doesn't like
Hassan. >> Don't we have to wait, we should uh we should
actually graph over time. It would be fun to graph all of the
Twitch pole adjacent people of like who the bigger is at any
given moment in time and their flip-flops between Hassan and
Trump. I feel like that would be very interesting to me cuz it
it like swaps back and forth over time. It's very interesting.
I don't know. Anyway, much longer we got soy pill on here for
quite a bit longer. There's somebody else calls in though. I'm
guessing uh I'm guessing he like slows down once more people
call. >> A lot of people don't know who the [__]
Charlie Kirk is. So they're hearing this and they're like what's
going on? What's going on? If Dem politicians are now coming
out and matching Donald Trump's rhetoric, if that's what you're
advocating for, like Demoliticians coming out and saying, "Hey,
you know what? No, this is the rights problem in the same way
that he's like, "Yeah, after this shooting, I'm going to crack
down on the left wing." That's insane because these people who
have no idea what the is going on with a Charlie Kirk assassination
are now going to see like the politicians they otherwise would
have supported like falling into the same like fascist rhetoric
that Trump is. And and like where does that get us? Those people
are not going to keep
>> I think the leftwing are doing that though because that's
what the right keeps saying. No, I'm talking about like my progressive
liberal parents. I'm not talking about anybody. >> You
were lost four years ago. Like people are online. People know
this. People watch this [__] I've had Norman. >> I
promise you this is like online killed as I my like there's a
reason like why I'm going to go home tomorrow or or whatever
and talk to my parents. I'm going to be like, "Who the [__]
is Charlie Kirk? What the [__] is that Charlie Kirk
the guy who's made over 300 college?" I
>> what? I feel like to not know who Charlie Kirk is right
now, you would have to be like Helen Keller.
>> Yeah. I
>> campus visits Bill. Is that what you're saying? Your
parents your parents mentally disabled. They can't comprehend
the news. >> They can't turn on the TV. Is that what you're
saying? You got they can't live without assistance.
>> Somebody who's trying to complain. Like I understand
the comparisons with Paulie. I understand why people want to
make those comparisons, but it's like, okay, ain't no huge protest
of South Koreans carrying American flags going, we are Paul Pelosi.
We are Paul Pelosi. That doesn't exist, right? It's like trying
to compare the the waves, like the shock waves from Paul Pelosi
getting hit in the head with a hammer. People make jokes about
it versus like this. It's like it's totally understandable why
people are more upset about this or why this would be like more
offputting to normies, right? I think this is very clear. Um,
>> I guess that's way be more off, but I mean, [__]
him anyway.
>> It's like
at least you didn't say it was also pragmatic, but also also
offputting and also in the short run you lose and also in the
long run you lose. Okay. I'm sorry you didn't watch that whole
food shops call. It was uh >> No, I I No, no, I saw enough
to understand that. I did. I watched that happen. Um,
>> what do I think about it? I yeah, I think people don't
give a I think it's offputting to right-wingers and some people
in the in the middle, but I also think
it serves a dual purpose of kind of undercutting the importance
people want to place on it. >> I think I I think the issue
another issue is um cuz it's like because the right-wingers are
like the very low IQ like just the dregs, right? They're the
kinds of people who will always be like worried about the the
social issues. They'll always be thinking about this stuff. other
people have like things going on. Other people have like lives
or or bigger problems they think about and so it just won't stick
with them. Like I I think I think I think this kind of messaging
works against Democrats. I think Republicans have built a coalition
that's like with I don't know. There's like something going on
there that it's just you have to you have to accept so many like
bad things to try to emulate Trump and you've you've like lost
first mover advantage of trying to get those people in the first
place. I don't know.
You think between Israel and Epstein you could almost get it
back if there was like a populist candidate on the Dems though,
right? Like Trump totally bowing to Israel. But you'd have to
do some crazy signaling I think to try to grab like a significant
portion of that populist like vote. >> No, I I I actually
don't think you'd have to do that much. I I I think this more
effective than you give credit for even for them for left wings
everything. Wait, what are you talking about in terms of populist
signaling?
>> Like illusions to violence or at least putting them
in prison. Yeah, just being super aggressive. >> Um, calling
them works for sure. Also, because there's just way more evidence
that they are. Okay. Trump's white hat. That's just known. That's
just facts.
>> And $500 million. The guy who's calling Donald Trump
and has him appear on stage at event. None of them have any idea.
We're like, this guy is one of the most popular influencers in
the United States. you you're you're vastly overestimating the
fact that most people are not as politically tuned in as you
and I are. Like not even close. The people do not know who this
guy is. Like this is such a like online position to a degree.
Like if you asked like people that are hyper online like people
that I talk to that make YouTube videos, they don't even know
the difference between like Matt Walsh and like Michaels because
these people are like >> don't know. Sure, there are people
that are that unplugged, but we can't rely on those people to
save us anyway cuz it's not like >> they're the majority
of the voters. >> Yeah, but they're not going to be voting.
You're going to tell me that those people don't know who Charlie
Kirk is, but they're going to know when Matt Walsh points out
that a radical trans
when Joe Biden comes out and say we have to go after the right
wing in like a violent like fasy way that like the same go I'm
saying what I'm saying is that what they need to say is they
need to say we don't disavow until the right does. That's a super
easy ask. >> You don't think there's like a huge swath
of like not tuned in voters who if they saw Joe Biden say I will
not disavow a like a terrorist on the left wing that that would
push them away from Joe Biden. >> Then our country's and
we deserve to go to whatever the next Like he doesn't he doesn't
even understand how you would message this. You don't say that.
You would never say that. That's explicitly
to say. >> No, that's the thing. Our country's not
>> What you're talking about is you keep talking about
all these games we have to play when we have two actual here
that we have to pretend are normal adults. You're talking about
a politely maneuvered environment where there's a guy driving
us towards civil war and you >> describing politics and
crying that he has to do it, you know. Wow. We have to do messaging
and play games with the populace to try and get them on board
with. Wow. No way.
>> What is this? The action or practice of engaging in
political activity. >> Oh, hold on. Politicking has like
other meanings here. Gerand or prison. Okay, hold on. Engage
in political activity. I feel like politicking has a lesser known
or a like secondary meaning of like how you're kind of Yeah.
pandering to people, right? Feel like I I feel like Yeah. It's
just it is a performance. It's been a performance forever. >> Yeah.
Yeah. Exactly. >> On the left that apparently doesn't know
any legal event that's happened in the past 10 years to start
being a lawyer. And you got a Israeli Jew on the right who only
cares about trans issues and you're talking about how do we perfectly
message on the left while the V. >> Uh the show Yeah. Short
fat otaku sort of was like he's
I think he's got like bills to pay to be honest with you. I think
that's most of what it is. >> I just had to be real. I
think he's like an intelligent person. He's got some bills to
pay. That's I I think that's like the long and short of it. Well,
the
like everybody should be treated like a It's not a reason.
We're going It's the bare minimum thing to say, "Hey, we disavow
assassinations
on political targets." That is the easiest thing to [__]
do it. The president can't do it, but we can. But please, like,
in good faith, answer me this. Do you not see that there's a
potential like huge loss of voters on the left if they see now
like a real equivalence between the left-wing politicians being
okay with terrorist attacks like and they wouldn't feel like
a little disenfranchised like the people that I'm describing,
not
that don't care about January. Oh, let me just finish like the
people. >> There is a potential problem. If the liberals
are weak and gay, the liberals need to stand up and take a firm
position on it. I think you could very easily settle. I think
you should make the government shutdown about that when the budget
comes out. >> He's just like not weak and gay about >> He's
literally weak and gay. Like by
the whole conversation he's been behaving like the absolute biggest
as well. It's just like so crazy.
>> You should say, "Hey, we are not going to fund the government
unless Trump makes one of our conditions. Trump needs to make
a 5minute speech saying all political violence in the country
needs to end." And you know what? If that plays worse for the
liberals, if liberals, oh my god, Democrats are the president
of violence. I need to go for a conservative now then, bro.
>> How do you Does this How does this guy convince people
that he had like real conversations and [__] I This
is just >> It's like unlistenable to like I actually don't
see that much daylight between what he's doing and what food
shops does.
It's actually not that far apart. It's bizarre. It's so offputting.
He's just spuring. >> The lines sort of veer towards each
other. You know, it's just like cross over food shops. Slowly
rises. Destiny slowly falls. >> They reach an equilibrium
room somewhere in the middle. >> Bizarre uniform and all
sign up for whatever guard tower, concentration camp, whatever.
I'll care. All right.
What you just said is is a far cry from what I think you were
saying like 5 minutes ago. Right. If you're saying that
the same Twitter [__] saying, "What do you want to
do? What do you want to say? War say kill somebody. Say kill
somebody." I said, "Okay, look, if you're saying let's play dirty
easy." >> Yeah. Yeah. Let's shut down the government until
Trump disavows.
>> I'll I'll send that on to Cherry Porter Beller. She
She get a kick out of that. >> Like, you know, stocastic
terrorism is a perfectly good example of like this is the dirty
let's go terrorism >> or terrorism. What? Excuse me. Yes.
Thank you. Cuz he's being the stocastic terrorist. But yes, if
you're saying let's shut down the government, let's play toxicology
report suggests Charlie Kirk actually died of fentanyl overdose.
Not the little neck boowbo. I think that means boo boo.
Oh boy. We saw this. Okay, this is a little this is a little
better when the black guy did it. Okay, black guy did it better.
Let's withhold
>> funding. Like, yeah, all of these things are things
I'm totally okay with. That is not uh like if we don't do this,
we're deescalating. In fact, if anything, this is at least like
halfway as bad as they're doing. Like when Gavin Newsome's redistating.
In fact, if anything, this is at least like
>> Oh, that's him. Is that him with a pen or something?
I It sounds like a lighter >> Halfway as bad as they're
doing. Like when Gavin Newsome's redistricting, he's not doing
it unilaterally. He's literally saying, "Hey people, you should
vote on this." What I'm saying is that's a far cry away. In fact,
that is what people want. I think that's what we need to do right
now. I think that's going to invigorate the left wing. But if
you're then saying, okay, and also we have to match them on the
rhetoric, which is very different from let's fight them. Let's
go as hard as we can. That's very different from saying, "Yeah,
we don't disavow terrorists." That's completely different. >> You
have when one side wants to fight, you have two options. You
can either meet it or you can uh exceed it. Okay? You can feel
deescalate cuz you can't deescalate. If somebody comes up, what
you just said is an escalation. >> I'm just saying I just
want you to be clear that when you're talking about what I'm
talking about is not escalation. Tit for tat is not escalation.
Okay. >> No. No. It's escalation from the Democratic rhetoric
of not doing for 10 years. Like we don't know. This is finally
them fighting harder, right? >> That's fine. And if the
democratic rhetoric goes all the way back to where it was before,
whatever. You don't deescalate at all. If anything, it might
even get worse. There's a reason why only works when everybody
has nukes.
>> One person disarms. >> Wait, no. This is because
this is what I'm talking about. This is a spectrum, right? This
is not a dichotomy. I'm not saying we have to [__]
disarm. >> The disarmament thing is just a stupid thing.
It's like imagine um one side of the Cold War actually nuke the
other um in general and they're like we won't disarm like literally
that's the only thing. We won't disavow this until Russia says
that they don't want to nuke us. It's like, okay, I I understand
like where you're coming from. And I I can even understand like
do you feel they pushed you here or something, but it's like
probably the time to go, well, we won't do this until you stop
is not right after you shot one of their guys, right after one
of their guys got shot. It's like you you chill for a second.
You try to calm things down for a moment. This goes for even
nuclear armed nations. Even in the exact hypotheticals he's presenting.
That's what >> I'm going to do nothing and we have to be
like, "Oh, we're the better party and we can't say mean jokes."
Like you and I literally were on the same team of a debate saying
yes, let's joke about these. The difference is when you say let's
fight, let's shut down the government, let's redistrict. Like
these are all escalations, which I agree with, which we need
to do to fight back because this [__] is insane.
It is potentially existential. It's not so far that we need to
meet them on the level of let's endorse political terrorists
on our side. Like this is not for you yet, but for some people,
I mean, like it's cool for us because it doesn't matter at the
end of the day, I guess, right? But the Supreme Court just said
that if you go to LA and there's a brown dude doing agriculture,
you could ask him for his papers, right? Start rounding up and
deporting random people. I know it's a joke because Hispanics.
I agree. Okay, I'm racist, too, I guess. Whatever the if that's
the laugh, if that's the position, right, for how many people
is trans healthcare banned for now? And I again, these people
are jokes. Who the [__] cares? We're white and based.
I get >> You're preaching to the choir, dude. You will
not get me any of this. At some point, it's going to be, oh,
I can't get my certain type of medication anymore because RK
just banned SSRI or >> No, you're preaching the choir.
I agree with all of this. All of this the the difference is not
that I don't think any of that is like the worst ever. Some people
Yeah. are literally dying like we said. And the fact that we're
brushing off USA deaths is wild to me. But it doesn't matter.
That's besides the point. Like the idea that somehow any of that
would be helped by saying we're not going to disavow left-wing
terrorists is if I don't see how that doesn't do anything but
hurt us. >> How? Maybe it makes them afraid. Maybe maybe
when you go out. Maybe when you go >> You remember you
remember when you said prima fact and the bay already presumed
the worst. >> Maybe when you go out. No, no, >> wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait. Oh, he does actually just say it explicitly.
Okay. I wasn't sure he said it >> Vow leftwing terrorist
is said if I don't see how that doesn't do anything but hurt
us. >> How? Maybe it makes them afraid. Maybe maybe when
you go out. Maybe >> you remember you remember when you
said primaacta they already presumed the >> Maybe when
you go out. No. No. They No. But they >> is that Asmin
Gold's position? That's Asminold's position to a certain extent.
>> they don't really. They just sell it well because you
know >> I think Asmin Gold sort of targeted in in a way
that he has some plausible deniability in the previous position.
There's no plausible deniability with this position. Um I do
think Asmin Gold meant like in fear of their life though. >> I
think they don't give a [__] What do people do when
they're afraid? >> What if maybe they change? They adjust
their behavior. >> Yeah, but they also when you corner
a rat, it strikes out. When you have people living in >> I'm
glad I'm glad Wick can give us his uh personal fear
>> they Jesus >> strike out and >> the rat
strikes out as it cries out as strikes you. Is that what you're
alluding to here?
You think Wick's going in that direction right now? >> Yeah,
I think so. I saw >> it gets worse. Making them afraid.
Do you think that's going to help? >> You guys are so [__]
gay. Oh my god, it gets worse. The president does get worse
already. Maximally, he's already said the worst thing. >> This
guy keeps calling people gay. This guy's like a kiwi farmer.
I think this guy's like a Kiwi farmer school people gay. This
guy's like a [__] kiwi farmer, I think. >> So,
when do you start saying gay though? Seriously, when does this
come back? >> I don't know. I've Yeah, I've not been following
trying not to follow, you know, like not really s not really
uh you call it like sincere rhetoric.
So, >> yeah. I don't feel I almost got an F then. But yeah,
>> I felt Listen, if I want to watch serious politics,
I just open up the boss stream, okay? Wade through a little bit
of fashion advice and then we get to the real the real >> Oh,
you see you come with the politics. Stay for the fashion advice.
>> Okay, so you acknowledge we're not going to make them
more afraid, right? Can you Okay, I you just know you just contradict
yourself. You just said the president is at the worst level.
I agree and we're not contradicting. >> This is what I'm
saying. This is what I'm saying. They're already
he gets it. >> So gets it >> posting. They have no
fear. They don't care for Matt Walsh to type that statement out.
I don't even know if I would have the balls to go on like, "All
right, guys. We need to do the worst to them, right?" I am already
knowing that the things that I'm saying means I'm probably going
to have to postpone or cancel the next couple events that I do.
The fact that all of them feel right now on the right that they
can operate with absolute and utter impunity. >> He's out
like crazy. >> He's Yeah, he's just done. Listen, >> be
late, Z. Sorry, Z. But how could they wait? How could they even
>> tonight? Hit that Mac tonight. Sorry, Z.
>> How How could any of the people like I don't I It's
just like with the positions they're taking, it's like feels
so disingenuous. You like ally you you align yourself with this
guy. You like get all your quote from this guy and then he's
sitting here like totally undercutting any of your positions.
It feels so super It feels so weird. Take it on the chiny. Jesus
Christ. >> Because the president is protecting them because
the left is weak. Because nobody wants to say do anything. Some
there are some chilling effects that are good. You should be
afraid to go out on media. Shut up the [__] You should
be afraid. You should be afraid to go on news channels and say,
"I think we should have a war. I think that we need a [__]
war." >> And the method of imposing that fear should be
to like approve of people taking their lives. It's just to be
>> Well, on the right right now, that's where they're at
is is yes, it's people based in awesome because we can just say
the left did it. >> Wait. Okay. >> Do you acknowledge
that right now people on the right seem to have no fear whatsoever?
or at least the the media guys seem to not really give a >> Well,
that this is what I'm getting to is it sounds like what you're
advocating for is we need to make the right afraid by having
more leftwing terrorists and even endorsing them because that's
the only way to >> in a reaction to a leftwing like
literally their their reaction to us like one of their most politically
connected um influencers has been a little disturbing to me and
I think that means we have to more
okay I mean that's a that's a take
I'm just saying you don't have to out and try to call it out
all the time. Why is it so hard to just say that? My answer is
if somebody asks you to disavow, you say, "Hey, you know what?
I would love to disavow, which I would cuz violence is bad."
Which it is because it makes me scared, which it does. I just
want the president of the United States, the leader of your movement
to do it first. Why is it so hard? You >> Because that
does nothing. You You and I both already both acknowledged that's
going to do absolutely nothing. He's not going to do it. So,
what's the point? >> Yeah. Then we're >> What do
you mean? No, because we're not necessarily if we can get out
of the situation without endorsing more political terrorists
on the left wing. >> Okay, then keep doing it. We'll see
what happens. That's fine. >> Let's just high level. >> Okay,
guys. Just lowest common. We have to actually >> I read
I read an article on tip for tat and if we don't go to the lowest
common denominator immediately, we uh we we lose. Okay. We just
have to act like the president of the United States without any
of the power or anything. Okay. We just have to act like him.
Okay. Sounds sounds like >> sounds like that's possible.
so far at all. So far, it's been a losing strategy. So, and historically,
it's never worked. So, but who knows, maybe this will be the
one time it does. >> So, Phil, you're welcome to stay if
you >> Okay. Thank god. Okay, guys. We're out. All right.
Thank you very much for watching tonight. I'll be back tomorrow.
I'll be back tomorrow.
Accept defeat. Myo nationalism wins. Is that what you guys are
calling it now? Coer, you've you've decided to be more a little
more accurate with your branding. Myo nationalism. All right.
Latino Zoomer, welcome back. He's back in the house. Okay, mystiso
nationalism. It's on
raid. Who are we raiding? Let me see.
We got online. Go watch this do his. Okay. Love you guys. Be
back tomorrow.